la séance est ouverte
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les députés chers
collègues
j'ai l'honneur d'accueillir
nous avons l'honneur d'accueillir
aujourd'hui dans notre émission monsieur
rousselland Stéphane chouk président de
la Rada ukrainienne
il y a quelques mois une délégation de
l'Assemblée nationale s'est rendue à
Kiev
j'étais à sa tête et nous sommes allés
dire la pluie indéfectible des députés
français à l'Ukraine et à son peuple
le président Stéphane chouk nous a
accueilli chaleureusement
avec lui nous sommes allés au contact
des Ukrainiens nous avons vu leur
extraordinaire résistance leur
détermination à se battre contre
l'agresseur russe et leur premier
efforts pour reconstruire le pays
à cette occasion monsieur le Président
de la radar vous nous avez demandé
d'être votre porte-voix auprès de
l'opinion publique française et
internationale et c'est ce que nous
avons fait
le 30 novembre dernier en effet
l'Assemblée nationale à l'issue d'un
débat nourri a voté une résolution
affirmant le soutien de l'Assemblée
nationale à l'Ukraine et condamnant la
guerre menée par la Fédération de Russie
depuis plusieurs députés se sont rendus
à Kiev pour marquer leur soutien
aujourd'hui pour la venue de Monsieur
Stéphane chouk l'Assemblée nationale
Arbor les couleurs
ukrainiennes avec l'exposition des
œuvres de Christian guemi que nous
venons d'inaugurer ensemble puis
plusieurs réunions associant nos
commissions permanentes et le groupe
d'amitié France - Ukraine nouvellement
constituée
l'agression russe se poursuit effroyable
avec son lot d'exaction et de crimes de
guerre de bombardements aveugles et de
destruction chaque jour apporte de
nouvelles accablantes mais aussi chaque
jour les démocraties s'unissent pour
apporter tout le soutien nécessaire à
l'Ukraine
car le crâne doit gagner cette guerre
elle doit retrouver son intégrité
territoriale et la paix
[Applaudissements]
pour la soutenir dans ce combat la
représentation nationale est pleinement
mobilisée aux côtés du gouvernement
français car le combat de l'Ukraine est
plus largement celui de nos valeurs
démocratiques celui de l'humanisme de la
liberté aussi nos deux assemblées
viennent-elles de signer un protocole
d'accord particulièrement
utile pour préparer l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne en effet
l'Ukraine fait partie de la famille
européenne et son destin se trouve dans
l'Union monsieur Stéphane chouk
président quand vous reviendrez à Kiev
vous pourrez témoigner de l'entière
mobilisation de la représentation
nationale française en faveur du peuple
ukrainien et de sa souveraineté
c'est avec beaucoup d'émotions beaucoup
de plaisir et beaucoup d'amitié que je
vous aide à présent la parole et que je
vous invite à monter à la tribune de
l'Assemblée
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
pour cette possibilité
de prendre la parole devant les députés
de l'Assemblée nationale française
au coeur même de la vie politique de
votre pays
il est très important pour nous que nos
amis partenaires puissent entendre les
Ukrainiens
comme vous l'avez fait madame pendant
votre visite à l'Ukraine
je me souviens jusqu'au moindre détail
de votre visite à cueillent ensuite nous
sommes rendus ensemble en train dans la
ville voisine de Turny c'était un acte
de courage
je n'oublierai jamais madame la
Présidente
comment vous avez tenu les mains
âgée qui a survécu après
frappe de missile sur sa maison vous
avez pu voir de vos propres yeux
l'ampleur de destruction de notre pays
vous avez ressenti la douleur et le
malheur de chaque ukrainien votre visite
est devenue un témoignage éclatant de
solidarité de la République française
avec l'Ukraine la manifestation de
soutien de notre indépendance et de
notre intégrité territoriale
des principes qui nous réunissent
ce qui nous réunit aussi sont les ponts
fraternelle a transmis à la région de
Tchernia
renforcer les ponts d'amitié et d'aide
monétaire entre les deux pays et on
était renforcés par les ponts de soutien
militaire et technique
accorder à l'Ukraine
l'aide militaire et les équipements et
nous construirons absolument de nouveau
pont qui vont réunir encore davantage
nos deux pays cela fait presque non que
l'agression à grande échelle de la
Russie contre le crâne
d'autres ne comprenant parfaitement que
son unique
intention était l'aspiration criminelle
de la Russie de s'emparer des
territoires
étrangères privés ou l'Ukraine de
souveraineté empêché notre avenir
européen et euro-atlantique la Russie
utilise contre nous l'ensemble des
arceaux dont elle disposent elle fait
chanter le monde donc d'utiliser les
armes aujourd'hui
360 ans se sont écoulés depuis cet
instant l'Ukraine résiste le crâne se
bat car aujourd'hui aussi elle n'imagine
pas sa vie sans la liberté
entre résistance l'agresseur répond par
les attaques contre nos villes nos
villages les sites d'infrastructures qui
privent les gens de chauffage
d'électricité d'eau
seulement aujourd'hui
depuis ce matin les
Ukrainiens sont descendus à trois
reprises dans les abris pour sauver leur
vie des missiles russes
l'agresseur
aspire à priver les Ukrainiens des
conditions dignes d'existence la
propagande cynique russe continue à
produire des mensonges des fake en
utilisant une erreur aussi bien ses
propres concitoyens que tous ceux qui le
encore dans le monde mais de fait ils
sont
donc participe à ce crime qui doit être
puni et tous les responsables doivent
être traduits devant la justice ce sont
les terroristes qui
font cela et c'est ainsi qu'agi un
régime terroriste et un état terroriste
il s'agit d'une politique agressive et
irresponsable qui porte la menace pour
la liberté la démocratie la communauté
internationale doit y apporter une
appréciation adéquate ainsi le 23
novembre l'année dernière le Parlement
européen a reconnu la Russie comme État
promoteur de terrorisme qui utilise les
méthodes terroristes les décisions
identiques avaient été prises par les
assemblées parlementaires de l'OTAN et
du Conseil de l'Europe par conséquent à
cette haute tribune je vous appelle
chers collègues à reconnaître la Russie
en tant qu'État terroristes dans les
murs de votre temple de droits et de
liberté dans ces murs
[Applaudissements]
importantes et le 30 novembre de l'année
dernière la résolution de soutenir le
crâne adopté dans ses murs qui a
condamné l'agression russe en fait
partie ce qui est important c'est que
cette résolution
soutient l'idée de création d'un
tribunal spécial et c'est ce tribunal
qui doit établir chaque nom chaque
criminel depuis les idéologues de cette
agression encensée jusqu'à ceux qui ont
donné des ordres directs ceux qui ont
tué ceux qui ont violé ceux qui ont
mutilé personne ne doit échapper à sa
responsabilité car c'est cela la justice
depuis le début de cette agression à
grande échelle contre le crâne et avant
tout pour l'aide militaire notre
décision de renforcer le crâne avec des
systèmes de défense anti-aérienne de
fournir les chars et les blindés sont
devenus des impulsions pour les autres
pays à adopter les mêmes décisions la
France a toujours été et sera l'odeur
grâce à vous le lexique français
s'enrichit de nouveau mot
aujourd'hui nous savons
ce que signifie crotale
elle est Ruf 10
RC et nous sommes prêts à continuer à
enrichir notre vocabulaire avec d'autres
mots
[Applaudissements]
parmi les Léopards les Abrahams les
challengers
l'éclairs français qui nous renforcerons
au sol mais également les mirages et les
rafales qui ensemble avec d'autres
avions de nos alliés protégeront le ciel
ukrainien
donnez-nous les avions
donne-nous les ailes de notre victoire
et ses ailes
[Applaudissements]
mais aussi l'ensemble de l'Europe chère
membre de l'Assemblée nationale la plus
grande valeur
que nous partageons c'est l'être humain
et je remercie le peuple français
toutes les familles françaises qui ont
accueilli les
Ukrainiens
[Musique]
au nom de chacun des cent mille de mes
concitoyens qui ont trouvé refuge en
France vous avez donné aux enfants
ukrainiens
[Applaudissements]
notre peuple
connaîtra une
floraison au sein de la grande famille
européenne nous travaillons sur les lois
et l'introduction des réformes
nécessaires nous savons ce que nous
devons faire et comment le faire nous
avançons le plus vite possible même dans
les conditions de la guerre
je voudrais souligner que le président
de l'Ukraine le Parlement et le
gouvernement
font preuve de tolérance zéro à l'égard
de la corruption et se battent pour
éradiquer ce phénomène seulement en 10
derniers jours il y a eu des démissions
des fonctionnaires de haut niveau peu
scrupuleux qui seront condamnés qui
répondront de leurs actes car c'est cela
la démocratie
terminera le plus vite possible et
accomplira
toutes les mesures établies par la
Commission européenne j'espère que ça ne
permettra dès cette année d'ouvrir les
pour parler pour l'entrée à l'Union
européenne nous espérons également que
la France donnera le soutien politique à
la demande du craignant de son adhésion
accélérée dans le temps dans le contexte
du sommet de l'Alliance qui aura lieu à
Vilnius le 11 12 juillet 23 car nous
avons prouvé par notre lutte que nous
pouvons et nous devons devenir membre de
la famille européenne de l'Union
européenne mais aussi de l'Alliance
atlantique chère Assemblée nationale
nous récurrons souvent à l'histoire nous
y cherchons les explications de ce qui
se passe et de ce qui nous arrive
aujourd'hui et je voudrais évoquer ici
dans ce noble cercle en phénomène et un
événement historique qui s'appelle
[Musique]
qui a été évoqué par l’historien
français Laurent Rucker suite aux
actions génocidaires du régime de
Staline en raison de cette famine
artificielle organisée en 32 33 des
millions du kenyen ont péri
et c'est aujourd'hui le signal venant de
France en reconnaissance la famille leur
demande en tant que je ne cite sera un
signal fort et important car comme par
le passé le régime soviétique
aujourd'hui et le régime de Poutine
n'aspire qu'à une chose détruire la
nation
ukrainienne
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande de contribuer à la
reconnaissance législative de la famille
32-33 en tant que jeune acide du peuple
craignant
chers amis cette guerre
se terminera par notre victoire commune
j'en suis persuadée et après cette
victoire viendra la période de
reconstruction et de la restauration
nous espérons aussi que la France votre
gouvernement va au milieu d'affaires
pourront se joindre de manière active à
cette reconstruction de l'Ukraine de
l'après-guerre cette reconstruction doit
constituer l'histoire de succès de
l'ensemble du monde civilisé chers amis
aujourd'hui je m'adresse à vous au nom
de tous les Ukrainiens qui se battent
aujourd'hui qui donne leur vie pour leur
liberté leur dignité aujourd'hui je
parle au nom des citoyens
ukrainiens qui ce jour même aide l'armée
continue à travailler à étudier en
croyant en leur victoire et la vie
Pacifique nous voulons vivre dans une
société pacifique et civilisée que
personne ne menace et c'est pour cela
que nous proposons les formules de la
paix au sommet de juin le président de
l'ainsky a proposé aux leader mondiaux
un plan de fin de la guerre et notre
formule de la paix constituée de 10
points nous voyons que la France est un
leader puissant et qui aidera à réaliser
ce plan c'est précisément grâce à l'aide
de la France et de nos autres
partenaires et alliés que nous voulons
fixer les points clés de la structure
post-guerre dans l'espace eatlantique
comprenant les garanties pour l'Ukraine
et nous comptons beaucoup sur le soutien
de cette formule de la proposée par le
président
ukrainien de la part de la France
à l'U tout le monde doit parfaitement
entendu les paroles de président Macron
nous serons ensemble pour construire un
monde juste et solide comptez sur la
France comptez sur l'Europe nous avons
entendu ces paroles sous les tirs nous
les avons entendu sur le champ de
bataille et ses paroles ont retentit
plus fort que les explosions des obus et
les sirènes de l'alerte aérienne chers
amis en guise de conclusion
permettez-moi de cette haute tribune de
partager avec vous un rêve je me
souviens comment en 2012
lors de l'Euro 2012 il y a eu un match
entre les équipes nationales de France
et dukraine et cela a lieu à Donetsk au
stade d'honnebas Arena et ce match a été
interrompu par un orage et moins de deux
ans plus tard
l'agression russe l'occupation a
interrompu notre vie Pacifique la guerre
est entrée dans notre maison pourtant la
mort et la destruction
et je voudrais
gagner ensemble dans cette match contre
la mort et que nos équipes nationales
puissent de nouveau jouer dans Donetsk
libérée à Donbass Arena
ches
de notre victoire commune ça sera le
match de la paix et de la mémoire
ce sera le match de la nouvelle vie je
vous remercie de votre attention gloire
à l'Ukraine et vive la France
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci au nom de la représentation
nationale mes chers collègues je vais
vous proposer de suspendre juste deux
minutes le temps que le président
Stephen puisse s'installer dans la
tribune que nous avons pavoisé aux
couleurs de l'Ukraine et nous aurons
ensuite les interventions de chaque
groupe politique ainsi que nous en avons
décidé en conférence des présidents donc
juste deux minutes de suspension je peux
vous propose de rester à vos places nous
reprenons dès qu'il est installé en
tribune merci
Noël nous sommes toujours en direct de
l'Assemblée nationale où vous venez de
suivre le discours du président du
parlement
ukrainien qui passe justement juste à
côté de moi russe last Stephen chouk qui
vient donc de quitter l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale pour monter dans
les tribunes et assister désormais à
cette séance de questions au
gouvernement qui va démarrer par pas
moins de 10 questions puisque chaque
groupe politique va prendre la parole au
tout début donc sur l'Ukraine une séance
qui est en partie réservée à l'Ukraine
avec cette visite officielle du
président de la Rada Ruslan Stéphane
Chuck donc à l'invitation diale brume
pivey il vient de s'exprimer dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
pour remercier bien évidemment la France
pour son soutien humanitaire et
militaire il a d'abord remercier la
présidente de l'Assemblée de lui
permettre et bien de pouvoir prendre la
parole ici à l'Assemblée et de faire
entendre la voix de l'Ukraine et
ukrainien il a dit que l'Ukraine
résistait et continuerait à se battre il
a dénoncé évidemment l'agresseur russe
qui prive de tout la population
ukrainienne trois alertes effectivement
ont été entendues depuis ce matin des
missiles russes ont été envoyés il a
demandé à la France de reconnaître la
Russie comme un état terroriste et puis
il a aussi dit sa volonté de devenir
membre de l'Union européenne et de
l'Alliance atlantique elles a mon
ningava vous êtes salle des quatre
colonnes on va pas vous retrouver parce
que ça y est la séance vient de
reprendre je vous propose de suivre la
séance de questions au gouvernement et
on se retrouve juste après de 3 minutes
et donneront lieu à une réponse groupée
de madame la Première ministre la
première intervention va être celle
d'ordre du président Chassaigne pour le
groupe GDR Président chassen vous avez
la parole
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre des enfants des femmes frappées
par les bombes jetées sur les routes par
millions des centaines de milliers de
civils et de soldats tués voilà le
terrible bilan de la folie meurtrière
déclenché voici près d'un an par le
sinistre Poutine qui a fait le choix
irresponsable d'envahir l'Ukraine le
choix du sang et des larmes violant les
règles du droit international mettant en
péril la sécurité en euros relançant une
désastreuse course aux armements ce
constat implacable nous rappelle une
évidence trop peu évoquée en ces heures
de déchaînement de violence notre seul
horizon doit être celui de la paix oui
la paix sans que cette exigence ne
puisse être perçue comme un signe de
capitulation car il y a bien un
agresseur il est clairement désigné et
un pays en état légitime défense que
nous soutenons sans ambiguïté
peu importe les moyens de se défendre
pleinement c'est dans ce cadre là que
doit continuer de s'inscrire notre
engagement militaire avec la volonté de
ne pas devenir cobelligérant et de ne
pas contribuer à une dangereuse escalade
guerrier par la livraison d'arme lourdes
offensive qui serait bien plus qu'un
simple enrichissement du vocabulaire
nous avons aussi un devoir tout aussi
important celui de porter assistance à
une population courageuse plongée dans
le tumulte et le chaos c'est ce que nous
faisons dans nos communes depuis le
début du conflit grâce à l'action des
élus et des bénévoles à la générosité
des familles d'accueil de réfugiés je
veux saluer ici ce mouvement fraternel
cette manne tendue à nos amis Ukrainiens
représentés aujourd'hui par le président
de son Assemblée nationale ce soutien
passe aussi par la recherche d'une
solution diplomatique le plus la plus
rapide possible comme le les mouvements
pacifistes de l'Ukraine et de la Russie
ouvrir les chemins de la paix à
l'inverse d'une escalade guerrière dans
laquelle aucune limite ne serait plus
posée dans l'utilisation des armes les
plus destructrices n'oublions jamais
chers collègues les 80 millions de morts
des deux guerres mondiales du siècle
passé c'est la raison pour laquelle il
nous semble urgent de remettre l'ONU au
centre des discussions membres
permanents du Conseil des sécurités de
l'ONU la France un rôle important à
jouer dans ce cadre-là madame la
Première ministre La France est-Elle
prête à engager des moyens diplomatiques
plus importants auprès de l'ONU pour
parvenir à un cas de sécurité collectif
durable et acceptable par toutes les
parties impliquées êtes-vous prête aussi
à répondre favorablement à la demande
que j'ai formulée avec mon collègue
Fabien Roussel au nom de groupe de la
Gauche de brouates républicaines pour
que je sois organisé ici même un débat
sur la de la France concernant la
livraison d'armes
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame la
présidente merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre monsieur le
Président de la radar notre groupe
parlementaire de la France insoumise
nupes souhaite tout d'abord adresser
tout son soutien à ses homologues
députés Ukrainiens ainsi qu'au peuple
ukrainien meurtri par la guerre nous
formons le vœu qu'une solution
diplomatique soit trouvée au plus vite
afin de garantir le retour à la paix
madame la Première ministre oui il
relève Dieu de Dieu voir de la France de
soutenir l'Ukraine d'aider les
Ukrainiens y compris militairement
toutefois ces derniers jours l'Allemagne
les États-Unis et d'autres pays ont
annoncé la livraison d'armes lourdes à
l'Ukraine notre préoccupation est double
que les Ukrainiens puissent se défendre
face à l'agression des Russes et que les
risques de monter en puissance dans le
conflit soit t'éviter
indépendamment du fait de savoir si nous
disposons des stocks suffisants ou si
nos équipements sont adaptés pour nous
engager dans cette voie nous partirons
tous ici la volonté de ne pas alimenter
une logique d'escalade et de précipiter
notre pays au seuil d'une guerre totale
le président de la République lui-même
est conscient de ce danger ils ne disait
pas autre chose en octobre 2022 dans les
termes suivants nous soutenons l'Ukraine
dans sa résistance sans participer à la
guerre parce que nous ne voulons pas de
guerre mondiale nous partageons cette
position c'est pourquoi nous demandons à
ce qu'un débat soit organisé à
l'Assemblée nationale sur le rôle que la
France doit tenir pour cela les
parlementaires doivent pouvoir disposer
des informations stratégiques afin
d'éclairer leur réflexion la gravité de
ces enjeux mérite un débat démocratique
et je sais que plusieurs groupes sur des
bancs différents ils sont favorables par
ailleurs madame la Première ministre
l'invasion russe en Ukraine pose la
question à long terme de la
reconstruction du pays notre Assemblée a
reçu récemment en commission des
affaires étrangères sur proposition de
notre groupe une délégation des
défenseurs de l'environnement ukrainien
parmi lesquels une députée de la Rada
une de leurs revendication et la prise
en compte des conditions sociales et
écologiques dans le processus de
reconstruction les saccages causés par
l'armée russe en Ukraine ne doivent pas
laisser place à des ravages causés par
la prédation des multinationales madame
la Première ministre j'espère qu'à ce
titre vous vous désolidarisez des propos
du président délégué du Medef tenu à
Bercy au sujet de la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine je cite c'est l'occasion
pardon de l'expression de tirer parti de
ce qui s'est produit la période appel à
la décence et les horreurs de la guerre
ne seraient représentées une opportunité
économique nous voulons là aussi un
débat dans notre assemblée sur les
modalités de l'aide française et
européenne à la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine afin que notre Parlement soit
associé à ce processus
pour finir permettez-moi d'adresser au
nom de mon groupe un soutien politique
et humaniste au peuple ukrainien qui vit
la terreur et l'horreur ainsi qu'aux
russes qui subissent et s'opposent à
cette guerre voulue par Poutine je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente
la parole est au président Marley pour
le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
à travers vous monsieur le Président
c'est l'engagement le courage et la
résistance du peuple ukrainien que nous
voulons honorer cet après-midi jour
après jour il force l'admiration du
monde parce qu'il n'y a aucun doute pour
nous oui la Russie a violé la
souveraineté ukrainienne et porte seule
la responsabilité du retour de la guerre
en Europe avec son cortège insensé de
crimes contre l'humanité de bout de chat
à carquif la France doit aider l'Ukraine
et notre pays n'a pas cessé d'étendre
son soutien militaire humanitaire et
financier
mais madame la Première ministre le
conflit figé depuis l'automne connaît
des mouvements inquiétants depuis
plusieurs semaines avec la perspective
d'une offensive russe de grande ampleur
qui pourrait aligner jusqu'à un
demi-million de nouveaux conscrits le
président Poutine est habité par les
idées de destruction et de reddition de
l'Ukraine engagé dans une guerre qui n'a
aucun sens politique ou économique sauf
à vouloir reconstituer le glacis
soviétique un fil même ténu de
communication avec l'agresseur a été
maintenue depuis le début du conflit
mais les espoirs de retrouver une porte
de sortie négociée à court terme
s'amenuisent devant l'intransigeance
russe bien sûr aucune négociation n'est
possible tant que l'Ukraine est sous les
bombes
aujourd'hui la France grande puissance
puissance européenne puissance membre du
de droit du Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU
invocation à imaginer la fin de la
guerre aujourd'hui pourtant elle ne fait
pas entendre sa voix singulière notre
pays donne le sentiment d'être à la
remorque de ses partenaires européens et
de son allié américain parfois en
décalage avec eux en tout cas sans
initiative propre ce n'est pas à la
hauteur de notre histoire sans doute la
position française souffre-t-elle
de l'isolement du président de la
République jusque dans son propre pays
une des seules démocraties dans laquelle
le chef de l'État ne partage pas ses
opinions stratégiques avec le Parlement
vous devez madame la Première ministre
vous appuyez sur le Parlement pour
construire la position française et
notamment partager avec nous un état des
lieux réaliste de nos capacités de
soutien militaires nous dire quels sont
les scénarios de des escalades et de
paix pour l'Ukraine qui guide votre
gouvernement madame la Première ministre
la solidarité de la France envers le
peuple ukrainien sera d'autant plus
solide quel sera éclairée et partagez
êtes-vous prêtes à organiser ce débat au
Parlement
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
la parole est à madame la Présidente
berger pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre monsieur le Président
la Rada dukraine est à l'instar de
toutes les assemblées démocratiques sœur
de notre Assemblée nationale votre
présence aujourd'hui est d'autant plus
symbolique que cela fait bientôt un an
que la Russie a déclenché ce qu'elle
refuse encore et toujours à admettre et
à appeler une invasion malgré des
dizaines de milliers de morts malgré les
bombes lancé sur Kiev car kif Kerson ou
encore Odessa malgré les milliers de
crimes de guerre torture viol attaque
délibérée et ciblée d'école et
d'hôpitaux exécution sommaire et les
souffrances infligées à tout un peuple
un peuple dont Vladimir Poutine et
depuis un an le persécuteur et le
bourreau systématique pourtant malgré le
déséquilibre des forces malgré
l'agression prémédité et massive de
l'armée russe l'Ukraine a tenu elle a
tenu d'abord grâce au courage de ses
citoyens et de ses dirigeants elle a
tenu aussi parce que nous oui nous
Français européen démocrate alliés sans
fléchir nous avons répondu présent en
sanctionnant durement la Russie quand
certains nous demandaient de cesser
toute sanctions et malgré le prix à
payer nous avons montré que nos valeurs
ne sont pas à vendre
en accueillant des millions du chrétien
fuyant les combats nous avons redis que
la fraternité n'était pas en 20 mots
enfin en fournissant un soutien à la
fois humanitaire et militaire à
l'Ukraine dont nous avons prouvé que les
intimidations ne nous empêcheront jamais
de venir en aide à un État souverain et
un peuple libre merci monsieur le
Président pour les mots que vous avez eu
pour notre pays et nos concitoyens car
oui dans toutes ces actions la France a
fait honneur à ses principes durant sa
présidence de l'Union européenne en
organisant en décembre un sommet qui a
permis de récolter des millions d'euros
d'aide d'urgence et de reconstruction
pour l'Ukraine la France là encore été
en début d'année par la voix du
président en annonçant la première
l'envoi de char de combat aux forces
ukrainiennes
à ceux qui posent la question jusqu'à
quand soutiendrez-vous l'Ukraine nous ne
donnons qu'une seule réponse jusqu'à la
victoire de l'Ukraine
nous serons à vos côtés tant que
l'Ukraine n'aura pas recouvré sa pleine
souveraineté les Ukrainiens leur liberté
nous serons à vos côtés pour célébrer
demain votre appartenance à l'Union
européenne
madame la Première ministre alors qu'une
nouvelle attaque massive de la Russie
est à craindre pour le printemps il nous
incombe encore et toujours de continuer
à soutenir les Ukrainiens aussi quels
nouveaux soutien militaire la France
entend-t-elle fournir en coordination
avec ses alliés pour soutenir encore et
toujours la résistance du peuple
ukrainien
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
merci beaucoup la parole est à madame la
Présidente Le Pen
madame la première minute monsieur le
Président chers collègue nous sommes
profondément touchés par le drame que
subit le peuple ukrainien c'est pourquoi
nous avons toujours condamné l'invasion
du territoire souverain de l'Ukraine et
appelé au rétablissement des principes
du droit international piétiné depuis
bien trop d’années par ceux qui
devraient les défendre cette guerre
européenne fratricide a vu naître une
remarquable mobilisation cherchant à
atténuer la souffrance de ceux qui
subissent cette guerre cette
mobilisation est le témoignage de notre
identité car elle ne sait pas seulement
faite par l'action des nations mais
également par des initiatives locales
rassemblant dans un même élan les
peuples et leur corps politique
l'accueil des réfugiés le soutien
matériel nécessaire à un peuple
souffrant du froid et de la fin est
admirable et si nous comprenons la
politique de livraison d'armes
défensives qui rejoint cette volonté de
défendre la souveraineté et l'intégrité
territoriale des nations il est légitime
de s'interroger sur une poursuite de
l'escalade dont l'issue vous êtes
inconnu la poursuite de cette guerre
n'est pas seulement un drame humain mais
risque de renverser définitivement
l'équilibre du monde la victoire
militaire de la Russie lancerait un
signal dramatique à ceux qui demain
pense pouvoir régler leur conflit
territoriaux par la force la livraison
au compte-goutte d'armement offensifs
probablement une guerre de Cent Ans un
engagement total de l'OTAN seule
hypothèse permettant véritablement
d'envisager une victoire de l'Ukraine
conduirait à une troisième guerre
mondiale sans résolution diplomatique du
conflit ce qui siège au Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU auront échoué à
défendre la paix ils seront retournés à
l'application de la loi du plus fort
Annie lent ainsi la souveraineté des
peuples et l'espoir de justice
internationale c'est pourquoi nous
soutenons les actions diplomatiques du
gouvernement en faveur de la paix
la stabilité géopolitique mondiale
conséquence des choix de la Russie nous
obligent à une grande prudence ne mes
estimons pas les nouvelles alliances de
la Russie qui séparait de l'Europe est
devenu un partenaire privilégié de l'un
et de la Chine alors que la paix a
disparu des consciences il est
nécessaire de commencer dès aujourd'hui
son édification et c'est pourquoi madame
la Première ministre je vous demande
solennellement si le président peut
faire entendre au monde qu'un espoir
demeure en organisant avec l'ensemble
des parties une grande conférence pour
la paix
je vous remercie
la parole est au président Marc Angeli
pour le groupe horizon
merci merci madame la Présidente et
merci monsieur le Président pour votre
intervention votre présence ici nous
engage monsieur le Président et je veux
au nom du groupe horizon et apparenté
que je préside vous réaffirmer tout
notre soutien comme j'ai d'ailleurs eu
l'occasion de le faire chez vous à Kiev
en décembre dernier
madame la Première ministre presque un
an après le début de la guerre en
Ukraine 90 ans après la plus grande
famine qu'a connu le pays voici que
resurgit le spectre de l'eau de mort
monsieur le Président en a parlé une
nouvelle fois la Russie menace la
sécurité alimentaire des peuples c'est
donc nécessairement l'affaire de tous
rappelons qu'avant l'invasion russe
l'Ukraine était le quatrième exportateur
mondial de maïs et de blé avec la guerre
la Russie a d'abord imposé un blocus en
mer Noire levé ensuite au prix d'apprent
négociation et d'un contrôle accru sur
les exportations maritimes depuis
s'ajoute au manque de carburant les
dommages continuent sur les
infrastructures de stockage et les
machines agricoles
les agriculteurs sont donc en première
ligne dans ce conflit il a fallu aider
l'Ukraine à écouler sa production malgré
les blocus la France et l'Union
européenne l'ont fait en créant un
corridor de solidarité dont la
logistique a permis de générer 15
milliards d'euros de revenus en Ukraine
mais les capacités de ce dispositif sont
limitées car son coût logistique et les
goulets d'étranglement sont présents
nous le savons pour qu'il continue de
porter ses fruits des investissements
supplémentaires devront être consentis
en plus de cela l'Union européenne
finance avec l'organisation pour
l'alimenter à l'agriculture un programme
de soutien pour les agriculteurs
Ukrainiens face à l'invasion russe
l'aide militaire est une nécessité à
court terme mais nous devons aussi nous
engager pour que ce conflit n'aggrave
pas une famine mondiale déjà fortement
accrue par les sécheresses sur le
continent africain madame la Première
ministre si à nouveau blocus devait
s'engager en mer Noire comment
pouvons-nous améliorer et pérenniser les
corridors de solidarité pouvons-nous
envisager d'autres programmes de soutien
aux agriculteurs Ukrainiens je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président
la parole est à monsieur le Président
Vallot pour le groupe socialiste
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre monsieur le Président
de la radam est cher collègue après
avoir entendu le président Zelinski
s'exprimait depuis qu'il dans ce même
hémicycle enfin de législature dernière
et rencontrer le Premier ministre
monsieur Chima dans l'enceinte de ce
palais Bourbon je veux remercier aussi
aujourd'hui le président de la radar
pour l'honneur qu'il fait à la
représentation nationale française par
sa présence je veux vous renouveler ici
madame la Première ministre devant le
président de la radale au soutien
indéfectible des députés socialistes et
apparentés aux actions et à l'aide en
faveur de l'Ukraine de la France et de
Lyon européenne menait depuis ce funeste
24 février
et évidemment soutenir les sanctions
décider à l'encontre de la Russie de
Vladimir Poutine et de ses dirigeants
nous avons eu vous le savez plus souvent
qu'un autre tour l'occasion de dire ce
soutien à travers le dépôt ou le vote de
résolution nous avons pu également le
faire de façon plus directe à travers la
voie de Valérie rabot lorsqu'elle vous
accompagnait madame la Présidente lors
d'un déplacement d'une délégation
française en Ukraine nous portons
aujourd'hui l'espoir avec beaucoup
d'entre vous et la conviction je dois le
dire que la victoire contre
l'obscurantisme du régime de Poutine et
non seulement possible mais demeure à
nous tous nécessaires
une victoire je le dis qui ne pourrait
être complète que lorsque l'Ukraine aura
recouvré sa pleine et entière
souveraineté c'est à dire ces frontières
internationalement reconnues celle de
une victoire qui nécessitera aussi la
mise en place d'un tribunal spécial
visant à établir et à juger les
responsabilités les crimes chromines
dans cette guerre une victoire qui
exigera la libération de tous les
Ukrainiens déportés en Russie ainsi que
l'indemnisation des crimes complies
accomplis pardon sur son sol cependant
madame la Première ministre je voudrais
aujourd'hui vous imposer sur une vous
interroger sur une autre aide que nous
devons à l'Ukraine si gagner la guerre
est un défi redoutable gagner l'appel à
paix civile durable après un tel conflit
n'en est pas moins un défi vertigineux
aujourd'hui dans la guerre l'Ukraine
fait montre d'une indéfectible unité
nationale et politique qui force
l'admiration mais demain après la
victoire le pays retrouvera ses
divisions politiques culturelles comme
partout ailleurs existait avant le
conflit mais ça c'est divisions se
superposeront des cicatrices les
traumatismes de la guerre l'expérience
de en Europe pour les uns de
l'occupation pour les autres de la mort
aussi et de les déportation en Russie
pour beaucoup l'expérience de la
résistance aux forces d'occupation ou au
contraire parfois de supplétif et des
lois déjà sur les questions de
collaboration viennent nous rappeler
cette réalité des tensions pourraient se
faire jour et avec elle une forme
d'instabilité alors ma question comment
on dès lors faire succéder à l'unité
dans la guerre l'unité dans la paix la
Concorde et la réconciliation madame la
Première ministre comment la France et
ses partenaires européens peuvent
réussir dans l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à
l'Union européenne se formidable défi de
gagner la paix intérieure comment les
autorités françaises aux côtés des
autorités ukrainiennes en lien avec les
partenaires européens peuvent-elles
anticiper ces défis essentielles je vous
remercie je vous remercie
la parole est au président bollange pour
le groupe démocrate
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre monsieur et madame les
ministres mes chers collègues
au-delà de la guerre et du devoir de
solidarité collective durable et sans
faille jusqu'à la libération de ce
peuple et le rétablissement de sa
souveraineté dans son territoire
internationalement reconnu au-delà de
cela je voudrais poser qui constitue
pour nous un impératif catégorique je
voudrais poser ici la question du sens
profond que revêt est à né aux yeux la
promesse d'adhésion de l'Ukraine à
l'Union européenne
porte-parole d'un groupe passionnément
attaché à la construction de l'Europe je
vous invite madame la Première ministre
à tordre le coup à l'idée perverse selon
laquelle cet adhésion sonnerait le glas
de l'aventure communautaire telle
qu'elle appelle des Français des
Allemands nous l'avons conçu et mener à
partir du 9 mai 1950 nous faisons modem
le Paris inverse car nous attendons ce
grand rendez-vous un double
enrichissement de notre projet commun
l'Ukraine nous apprend par son courage
et par son héroïsme que le droit n'est
rien quand la force n'est pas que
l'exemplearité veine quand l'esprit de
résistance est absent et que l'Union
ne sera qu'une apparence si elle ne
donne celle de se donne pas les moyens
d'armer ses valeurs grâce à vous chers
amis du crâne nous faisons enfin notre
les paroles que tu sidines prêtes à
Périclès il n'y a pas de bonheur sans
liberté ni de liberté sans vaillance
l'Ukraine nous rappelle au devoir de
vaillance mais nous lui proposons de
rejoindre le monde qui lui a toujours
été refusé un monde où la force nesclut
pas le droit où l'on sait qu'on ne
défend vraiment ses intérêts légitimes
qu'à la condition de prendre en compte
les intérêts légitimes des autres un
monde où les gens sans visage au lieu de
se dévisager un monde qui n'ignore pas
qu'il n'est pas d'élargissement qui
vaille sans un solide renforcement des
institutions communes c'est la rencontre
de ces deux exigences qui fera de
l'Europe un acteur à part entière en
1051 de Kiev fille de jaroslaf le sage
épousé Henri Ier le troisième capétien
est devenu ainsi reine de France Milan
ont passé depuis lors et la princesse du
crâne naguère lointaine et désormais
toute proche
nous
et de retour parmi nous puissions-nous
madame la Première ministre mes chers
collègues l'accueillir pour ce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui vraiment devenu une
immense figure de résistance qui s'est
donné pour mission d'arracher nos
peuples désorientés alors somnolence
historique et qui pour parler comme
Malraux porte aux yeux du monde
l'honneur de toute l'Europe comme un
invincible
merci président bourlange
la parole est à madame la Présidente
Chatelain pour le groupe écologiste
je vous remercie madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre monsieur le
Président de la Rada à travers vous
c'est le plus craignant que je sais de
saluer vous qui combattez avec courage
avec force avec détermination l'invasion
rouge face à vous le mythe de la
puissance russe s'est étonné je tiens au
nom du groupe écologiste à vous assurer
de notre soutien et de notre solidarité
dans ce combat l'Ukraine défend nos
valeurs la liberté et la démocratie je
sais que nous les partageons c'est
l'honneur de la France d'avoir pu
accueillir celles et ceux qui ont été
arrachés à leur maison à leur famille et
à leurs amis la Russie devl Vladimir
Poutine espérer isoler l'Ukraine de
l'Europe elle nous a fait nous
rapprocher nous peuvent nous jamais été
aussi liés et demain l'Ukraine une
Ukraine qui aura retrouvé son intégrité
territoriale sera pleinement membre de
l'Union européenne
face au retour de la guerre l'Union
européenne n'a pas failli des sanctions
étaient prises la solidarité
internationale européenne et française
s'est organisée pour finir pour fournir
de l'aide d'humanitaire et du matériel
militaire cette solidarité est
indispensable à la victoire la stratégie
de la Russie et de privé l'Ukraine et
Jésus Ukrainiens de tout la Russie
déprime d'énergie elle est prise de soin
elle éprive d'eau potable et elle veut
également les priver d'avenir car c'est
un lieu commun mais c'est tellement vrai
qu'il faut le rappeler la guerre brise
des vies c'est tout un peuple qui subit
les bombardements les tortures les viols
et la mort la guerre empoisonne les
terres ainsi la dispersion de munitions
et l'enfouissement de mines sur plus de
250 km² mais en danger la vie des
Ukrainiens et empoisonne les sols les
plus fertiles d'Europe la guerre saccage
un pays et son patrimoine 200 000
hectares de forêt ont brûlé 900 zones
naturelles protégées ont été touchés un
tiers des espaces protégés ont été
abîmés enfin cette guerre mais l'Europe
en danger les infrastructures nucléaires
ukrainiennes sont des cibles répétées
devenu un espace de conflit leur
sécurité n'est jamais complètement
garantie le nucléaire est ainsi un
danger pour l'Ukraine et pour l'Europe
le nucléaire est également une arme
d'influence dans un monde incertain
l'indépendance et notamment
l'indépendance énergétique est cruciale
pendant des années nous avons fait de
Poutine appartenaires politiques dans
nos relations internationales en raison
de nos dépendances aux énergies fossiles
aujourd'hui l'Union l'uranium russe peut
toujours être un outil de centrage de la
part de la Russie par l'intermédiaire de
l'entreprise rosatum nous devons mettre
un terme à tout ce qui nous contraint à
la dépendance envers la Russie madame la
Première ministre alors comment
comptez-vous libérer la France de ce
levier d'influence russe alors que
l'uranium a été exclu de l'embargo
décédé à l'encontre de la Russie
comptez-vous enfin émancipez la France
de ces fournisseurs d'uranium
autoritaires
je vous remercie madame la Présidente et
pour terminer le président nejlaine pour
le groupe liotte merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
monsieur le Président de la radar tout
d'abord je tenais à saluer le courage
des ukrainiennes et des Ukrainiens qui
depuis un an maintenant vivent sous une
menace constante et ils ont montré au
monde entier ce que l'engagement d'un
peuple à défendre son territoire veut
dire depuis février la Russie a fait le
choix de la guerre elle a fait le choix
de l'escalade et depuis la France est
aux côtés de l'Ukraine elle est aux
côtés du droit la France est en soutien
à un état voisin ami en détresse
et il est normal que la France prenne
toute sa part en soutien à l'Ukraine
c'est ce que nous faisons depuis le
devis début de ce conflit de manière
régulière de manière appuyée de manière
suivie nous apportons un soutien
diplomatique matériel et nous affirmons
notre sincère solidarité envers le
peuple ukrainien cette aide elle est
nationale portée par l'état français
mais elle est aussi à tous les niveaux
des strates des collectivités les
communes les départements et les régions
la région Grand Est un parfait exemple
en plus de sa diplomatie en plus de son
aide humanitaire en plus de son armement
notre pays possède une réelle expertise
dont de nombreux autres domaines nous
comptons de nombreux entreprises
françaises dont les compétences peuvent
et doivent être mises au service de
cette cause il faut mobiliser nos
acteurs économiques afin de venir en
aide à la population civile
ukrainienne afin de bâtir la paix car
après les temps de guerre viennent les
temps de paix et c'est ce temps que nous
appelons de nos vœux dès maintenant il
faut identifier les besoins du peuple
craignant viser les secteurs
prioritaires reconstruire les
infrastructures civiles détruites qu'il
s'agisse de l'accès à l'énergie à l'eau
au secteur agroalimentaire à celui de la
santé de l'éduquer de l'éducation du
transport ainsi madame la Première
ministre mes questions sont simples
comment se positionne la France
aujourd'hui pour son intégration à
l'effort et à l'urgence de
reconstruction de l'Ukraine maintenant
mais aussi sur le long le moyen et le
long terme et comment ce
coordonne-t-elle au niveau de l'Union
européenne je vous remercie
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la Rada Mesdames et
Messieurs les présidentes et présidents
mesdames et messieurs les députés
il y a près d'un an la Russie lançait
une offensive sur l'Ukraine une attaque
fondée sur des mensonges au mépris de
toutes les règles du droit international
une attaque brutale et meurtrière
depuis près d'un an l'Ukraine subit les
assauts et les bombardements russes
civils hôpitaux école et même qu'on voit
humanitaire sont ciblés mais depuis près
d'un an l'Ukraine résiste tient et
repousse les forces russes monsieur le
Président rousselens Stephen Chuck je
veux saluer votre présence à
l'invitation de la présidente Yaël Bron
Pivet à travers vous je veux dire mon
respect et mon admiration pour le
courage exceptionnel des forces armées
et du peuple ukrainien
monsieur le Président en attaquant votre
pays ce sont nos valeurs que la Russie
cherche à atteindre ce sont les droits
humains la liberté et la démocratie
qu'elle a voulu faire plier nous devons
défendre ces valeurs la lâcheté
aujourd'hui provoquerait les conflits de
main alors comme la assuré le président
de la République nous sommes et nous
resterons avec vous jusqu'à la victoire
mesdames et messieurs les députés le
soutien de la France de l'Europe et des
alliés passent d'abord par des
livraisons d'armements nous sommes l'un
des premiers contributeurs dans la
livraison d'équipements de munitions et
la formation de centaines de soldats
ukrainiens
ce sont des équipements qui font la
différence sur le terrain je pense aux
canons César au lance-roquettes unitaire
ou encore au système entier aérien
crotale début janvier le Président
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé la livraison
de Charles léger
amx-10rc répondant répondant à la
demande ukrainienne en matière de
blindée et lançant une dynamique depuis
d'autres pays ont annoncé la livraison
de chars à l'Ukraine nous sommes prêts à
étudier les demandes supplémentaires des
Ukrainiens en veillant au respect de
trois principes d'abord notre aide ne
doit pas provoquer d'escalade ensuite
elle doit être
utile et efficace rapidement enfin elle
ne doit pas affaiblir nos propres
capacités de défense
des capacités qui augmenteront
significativement ces prochaines années
comme le proposera la future loi de
programmation militaire
sur ces fondements le ministre des
Armées étudie les options possibles
chaque pays dispose de domaines
d'excellence et nous devons nous
coordonner au mieux avec nos alliés
par ailleurs nous avons créé un fond
spécial de soutien de 200 millions
d'euros pour permettre à l'Ukraine de
commander les équipements auprès des
industriels français enfin nous prenons
toute notre part dans la facilité
européenne pour la paix qui aide à
équiper et à former les forces
ukrainiennes
mais notre soutien à l'Ukraine ne se
limite pas à la question des équipements
loin de là
notre réponse face à l'agression ce sont
également les sanctions contre la Russie
en lançant cette guerre la Russie
pensait diviser l'Union européenne
elle a échoué au contraire nous avons
fait bloc moins de 24 heures après
l'attaque un premier paquet de sanctions
est adopté aujourd'hui nous en avons
adopté 9
finances banque commerce propagande
intérêt des oligarques ce sont des
sanctions fortes massives dans tous les
domaines
notre but est de rendre le coup de la
guerre insupportable pour la Russie
et n'en déplaise aux admirateurs des
régimes forts ces sanctions fonctionnent
paralysie du système productif
difficultés à réorienter les
exportations difficultés
d'approvisionnement la récession russe
devrait atteindre 5,5% en 2023 selon le
CDE
bien sûr cette guerre a des conséquences
sur nos compatriotes c'est pourquoi nous
avons mis en place des mesures les plus
protectrices d'Europe face à la montée
des prix la France est un des pays où
l'inflation est la plus faible en Europe
et avec le gouvernement nous
continuerons à protéger nos compatriotes
contre les conséquences du conflit
mesdames et messieurs notre soutien à
l'Ukraine est également diplomatique
il vise à isoler chaque jour davantage
la Russie sur la scène internationale
aujourd'hui les faits sont là l'adoption
des résolutions de l'Assemblée générale
de l'ONU de mars et octobre 2022 par une
très large majorité d'États l'a montré
j'ajoute que nous avons reconnu
pleinement l'appartenance de l'Ukraine à
la famille européenne je pense notamment
à la décision historique du Conseil
européen de juin qui lui a accordé le
statut de candidat à l'unanimité
mais notre soutien est aussi humanitaire
plus de 275 millions d'euros ont été
mobilisés et 2700 tonnes de matériel
livrées par la France
la conférence solidaire avec le peuple
ukrainien organisé à l'initiative du
Président de la République en décembre
dernier à Paris a permis de recueillir
un milliard d'euros d'engagements
nouveaux concentré sur l'aide d'urgence
pour permettre à l'Ukraine de passer
l'hiver pour sa part la France a donné
la priorité au secteur énergétique avec
notamment la fourniture de générateurs
électriques de haute puissance ou encore
de millions d'ampoules LED à l'Ukraine
la conférence a également abouti à la
mise en place du mécanisme de Paris qui
permet de faire le lien entre les
demandes exprimées par les autorités
ukrainiennes et les dons internationaux
ce soutien humanitaire va de père avec
l'accueil sur notre territoire de
personnes fillant la guerre plus de
100000 ressortissants ukrainiens ont été
accueillis et près de 20 000 enfants
scolarisés et je veux saluer ici la
mobilisation des associations des ONG
des collectivités et de nos concitoyens
j'ajoute que l'Europe a été au
rendez-vous la protection temporaire a
été accordée au déplacé
ukrainien c'était une première
en fin de notre soutien c'est accompagné
dès maintenant la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine à la conférence de Lugano
début juillet nous avons décidé de
parrainer la reconstruction de
l'aublaste de tcherny Yves selon le
mécanisme proposé par le président
zélinski une plateforme sur la
reconstruction réunit désormais les
membres du G7 et les institutions
financières internationales nous y
prenons toute notre part
en parallèle et après la conférence de
Berlin d'octobre dernier nous avons
mobilisé à Paris plus de 700 entreprises
pour contribuer à la reconstruction du
pays
au-delà de notre soutien à l'Ukraine
notre pays avec l'Europe tient son rang
face au crises provoquées par ce conflit
et notamment le risque de pénurie
alimentaire mondiale
dès le mois de mars dernier le président
de la République a pris les devants en
lançant l'initiative farm
l'initiative des corridors de solidarité
mis en place pour répondre au blocus
imposé par la Russie a permis d'exporter
plus de 23 millions de tonnes de
produits céréaliers du crâne par voie
terrestre
avec les exportations permise par
l'initiative céréalière en mer Noire ce
sont plus de 37 millions de tonnes de
produits agricoles qui ont été exportés
vers le marché mondial
dans le même temps nous soutenons les
efforts de la Roumanie en soutenant les
capacités logistiques de navigation dans
les ports de Galati et de sullina nous
livrer nous livrerons prochainement une
première pilotine mesdames et messieurs
les députés pourraient être efficaces
notre action doit être coordonnée sur
tous les sujets elle s'inscrit dans un
cadre européen dans ce contexte je me
réjouis qu'un sommet entre l'Union
européenne et l'Ukraine se tiennent ce
vendredi 3 février il sera l'occasion de
réaffirmer le caractère indéfectible de
notre soutien qui se chiffre aujourd'hui
après de 50 milliards d'euros tous
sujets confondus et surtout ce sommet
sera l'occasion de rappeler notre
volonté commune de poursuivre et
d'intensifier notre action
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
resterons aux côtés de l'Ukraine tout au
long du conflit mais la paix se
construira autour d'une table de
négociation nous saluons et nous
soutenons la proposition de paix en 10
points du président zenenski une fois de
plus l'Ukraine cherche les conditions de
la paix quand la Russie entretient les
conditions de la guerre avec l'Europe
avec les alliés nous serons jusqu'au
bout aux côtés des Ukrainiens jusqu'au
bout pour défendre nos valeurs et
jusqu'au bout nous protégerons les
Français des conséquences de la guerre
je vous remercie merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre merci au président
Stéphane chouk
[Applaudissements]
alors je suis heureuse de souhaiter la
bienvenue à nos deux nouveaux collègues
et lui dimanche dernier Monsieur René
Pilato député de la première
circonscription de Charente et Madame
Laure Miller député de la deuxième
circonscription de la Marne
je salue
et je salue également la réélection de
Monsieur Bertrand petit député de la 8e
circonscription du Pas-de-Calais
enfin je vous informe que j'ai reçu du
Conseil constitutionnel communication
d'une décision portant annulation
d'élections législatives des 12 et 19
juin 2022 dans la première
circonscription de l'Ariège à la suite
de laquelle madame Bénédicte taurine
avait été proclamée élu
donc nous allons à présent
commencer notre séance de questions au
gouvernement strictosensus et la parole
est à Madame Charlotte Leduc pour le
groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre vendredi dernier le
collectif nos services publics publié
une note qui a de quoi nous laisser
perplexe notamment en ce jour où nos
concitoyens défaire par millions dans la
rue pour vous dire en effet que le
retrait de votre réforme n'est pas
négociable cette note est intitulée le
déficit est-il artificiellement gonflé
pour justifier la réforme le déficit de
notre système de retraite par
répartition qui vous sert d'épouvantail
pour justifier de voler les deux plus
belles années de retraite à l'ensemble
de nos compatriotes ce déficit dépend
pour une part significative de l'emploi
public plus de masse salariales publics
c'est plus de cotisations dans les
caisses de retraite des fonctionnaires
territoriaux et hospitaliers or entre
juin 2021 et septembre 2022 les
projections d'emploi public produites
par Bercy par vos services et transmise
au corps pour réaliser ses calculs ont
été très fortement dégradées ces
projections prévoient en effet pour la
fonction publique d'État et territoriale
l'IMP de recruter au-delà du
remplacement des départs pendant toute
la durée du quinquennat soit une
rigidification des recrutements dans les
services publics inédits depuis 2012
concernant les salaires les hypothèses
retenues par le gouvernement prévoit un
quasi gel des rémunérations sur toute la
durée du quinquennat donc en réalité
avec l'inflation une baisse de près de
11% de la rémunération réelle des
fonctionnaires entre 2022 et 2027 c'est
la masse salariale publique évoluait
comme la masse salariale totale publique
et privée la moitié du déficit des
retraites serait comblée à horizon 2030
avec + 3,3 milliards d'euros de
cotisations alors madame la Première
ministre maintenant je vous pose
clairement la question envisagez-vous de
mettre en danger le fonctionnement de
nos services publics déjà à Loos tout en
rabotant drastiquement le pouvoir
d'achat des fonctionnaires déjà dans la
galère ou justifiez-vous votre réforme
injustifiable et brutale par un déficit
artificiellement gonflé et dramatisé où
se situe votre mensonge
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion
les députés madame la députée Leduc
permettez-moi d'apporter une réponse
d'abord à votre question précise et de
revenir sur ce qui sous-tend peut-être
l'idée générale de celle-ci vous évoquez
la question des hypothèses en matière
d'évolution de la rémunération des
agents publics tels que retenue dans le
rapport du corps d'abord un mot pour
dire que concernant les hypothèses
d'évolution de la rémunération de la
fonction publique et les effectifs pour
ce qui concerne la fonction publique
territoriale et la fonction publique
hospitalière le corps a retenu les mêmes
hypothèses que dans ces rapports
précédents qu'il n'y a pas de difficulté
majeure en matière de choix des
hypothèses et que la Caisse nationale de
retraite en charge de la fonction
publique et de la hospitalière et
territoriale accusé vrai un déficit de 6
à 8 milliards d'euros alors qu'elle
représente qu'elle couvre si vous me
permettez 10% de la population active à
peu près 10% des retraités pour ce qui
concerne la fonction publique d'État
l'argument que vous souhaitez déployer
ne tient pas il ne tient pas puisque
l'État assure l'équilibre du régime de
retraite des fonctionnaires de l'État il
assure à tel point que un taux de
cotisations qui est à plus de 35% pour
les à plus de 75% pardon pour les agents
administratifs à plus de 125% pour les
personnels militaires quel que soit les
variations de rémunération des agents
publics il n'y a pas d'impact sur le
solde du système de retraite une fois
que j'ai dit cela et j'espère vous avoir
convaincu que vos arguments ne tiennent
pas votre question me permet simplement
de rappeler que cette réforme est
nécessaire nécessaire pour une seule
raison nous avons nous avions dans les
années 70 trois cotisants pour un
retraité nous sommes aujourd'hui à 1,7
pour un retraité nous serons demain à
1,2 cotisants pour un retraité et cela
se traduit dans les chiffres avec un
déficit qui est dès 2023 est à 1,8
milliards d'euros par an et qui va se
creuser année après année pour atteindre
12 milliards et demi d'euros par an en
2027 et 25 milliards d'euros 2035 si on
ne fait rien madame la députée en disant
c'est 150 milliards d'euros de dettes
supplémentaires notre responsabilité et
c'est celle que nous allons tenir c'est
de sauver le système par répartition
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Laure Miller pour
le groupe Renaissance
madame la madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre Christophe Béchu en
charge de la transition écologique au
préalable permettez-moi juste quelques
instants d'exprimer ma fierté d'être à
vos côtés aujourd'hui pour la première
fois
exprimer aussi une forme de satisfaction
de voir le rassemblement national voilà
reculé dans notre hémicycle
également évidemment ma reconnaissance à
l'égard des électeurs de la deuxième
circonscription c'est un mandat
évidemment kimonore mais surtout qui
m'oblige ma question elle porte sur un
domaine dans lequel nous sommes majorité
très engagés particulièrement engagés
c'est celui de la préservation de
l'environnement et plus particulièrement
de l'amélioration de la qualité de l'air
je vais évoquer les questions la
question de la zone affaiblission les
aides et feu évidemment sont un outil
utile pour améliorer la qualité de l'air
sur nos territoires et sur un territoire
donné en tant qu'adjointe au maire de
Reims j'ai pu mettre en oeuvre une ZF
avec mes collègues élus locaux qu'on a
voulu la plus pragmatique possible et
qu'on a vu voulu la plus adaptée à notre
territoire pour autant j'ai ressenti et
nous ressentons une forme de défiance de
certains de nos concitoyens à l'égard de
ces effets une défiance d'ailleurs
largement instrumentalisée et alimentée
par le rassemblement national à
l'occasion de l'élection législative qui
vient de se passer ils ont choisi là un
nouveau cheval de bataille pour opposer
les Français les uns aux autres les
ruraux aux habitants de nos villes pour
utiliser les habitants les Français les
plus modestes aux Français qui ont
davantage de moyens et pour poser
également deux objectifs que sont
l'amélioration de la qualité de l'air un
objectif de santé publique avec celui de
la libre circulation de nos concitoyens
ma question est donc claire monsieur le
ministre est simple comment est-ce qu'on
peut améliorer comment est-ce qu'on peut
surtout accompagner nos concitoyens dans
la mise en oeuvre de ces aida pour faire
en sorte voilà que nos concitoyens
puissent considérer que c'est une mesure
juste donc d'accompagner en particulier
les plus modestes d'entre nous
d'accompagner aussi les habitants de
notre belle ruralité et pour faire en
sorte qu'on puisse concilier les deux
objectifs de santé publique et de
préservation
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
madame la députée Miller d'abord
félicitations et félicitations d'avoir
gagné sur votre nom et après avoir
effectivement été attaqué parce que vous
étiez adjointe à l'environnement d'une
ville qui avait mise en place une zone
affaiblissement et où le RN a eu de 16
de relater les mêmes fake news les mêmes
intox en expliquant qu'il s'agissait
d'abord d'une mesure pour ennuyer les
Français au lieu de les protéger
la manière dont la zone affecte les
missions a été mise en place à Reims
elle témoigne d'abord de l'intelligence
locale qui a consisté à faire de la
concertation s'il vous plaît à regarder
comment mettre en place des dérogations
pour les personnes atteintes d'affection
longue durée pour les déménagements pour
les artisans
permettant de montrer que là où les élus
locaux se sont saisis du sujet les
fantasmes qui sont véhiculés autour du
nombre de gens qui seraient interdits
d'accéder en ville ne correspondent pas
à la réalité
et l'enjeu il est simple il est d'abord
celui de préserver la santé de nos
concitoyens vous l'avez rappelé
47000 morts de la pollution
atmosphérique
2 à 3 ans de perte d'espérance de vie
donc même si manifestement certain en
plus d'être climatoceptique sont juste
sceptiques sur les cancers et sur le
type de maladie qui entraîne la mort
d'une partie de nos concitoyens les plus
fragiles l'honneur de la politique c'est
précisément de préserver de protéger les
plus fragiles y compris quand il s'agit
de tordre le coup à la démagogie à ceux
qui vous expliquent qui sont toujours
d'accord avec la finalité mais qui dès
qu'il s'agit de passer aux actes sont
aux abonnés absents bravo merci
bienvenue
merci Monsieur le Ministre un peu de
silence s'il vous plaît la parole est à
Monsieur Meyer Habib pour le groupe les
républicains
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre vendredi dernier nous
commémorions le 70e 78e anniversaire de
la libération du campus journée
internationale de la commémoration de la
Shoah 6 millions de Juifs 2 millions
d'enfants déportés gazées brûlés
victimes de la folie meurtrière de la
barbarie nazie dans le silence des
nations puis après 2000 ans d'exils
après l'acquisition après les programmes
cosaques après la Shoah le peuple juif
revient à Jérusalem sur sa terre
ancestrale en 1948 l'État d'Israël René
un État démocratique moral fort non que
soit clair l'État d'Israël n'est pas une
compensation de la Shoah le sionisme
existe depuis 2000 ans mais la réalité
que si l'État d'Israël existait à cette
époque
ignorait jamais eu la Shoah que rêve
aujourd'hui de refaire le régime
sanguinaire iranien vendredi c'est ce
jour symbolique un djihadiste a choisi
pour abattre à bout portant cette civile
devant une synagogue à Jérusalem dont
une réfugiée et craignait une crainienne
j'ai une pensée pour eux les familles
des victimes si la France a condamné je
m'en réjouis la gauche et certains
grands médias certaines gauches parlent
de Colon juive d'ultra orthodoxe pour
justifier un demi mot le terroriste qui
est le même qui fera pas Paris ou à Nice
pas un mot de condamnation de la part
des mêmes qui parlent deux jours plus
tôt avant de massacre quand Israël se
défend et élimine des bombes à
retardements aux humains avant qu'elle
ne passe à l'acte pour cette gauche tuer
des Juifs c'est de la résistance pire ce
sont les mêmes qui accueillent en héros
à l'Assemblée nationale salamouri k du
fblp organisation terroriste responsable
notamment de l'attentat chez nous de la
rue Copernic qui a ensanglanté la France
célébré dans le temple de notre
démocratie un terroriste qui a reconnu
avoir programmé l'attentat sur le Grand
Rabbin d'Israël c'est ça le nouvel
antisémitisme pas de l'antisionisme de
l'antisémitisme je répète madame la
Première ministre ne trouvez pas vous
intolérable la visite de salamory à
l'Assemblée nationale à 48 heures de la
rencontre du Premier ministre israélien
et du président de la République à
l'Élysée quels sont les gestes forts que
notre pays la France compte apporter au
gouvernement israélien dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme merci je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame
Catherine Colonna ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
habite je comprends votre émotion et je
la partage vendredi dernier de Jérusalem
une synagogue a été ciblée par un
Palestinien radicalisé dans une attaque
abject le jour de shabbat au sortir de
la prière et qui plus est le jour des
cérémonies de commémoration
internationale en mémoire des victimes
de la Shoah la France vous l'avez dit
Monsieur le Député aussitôt condamné cet
attentat dans les termes les plus clairs
et nos pensées je le redis vont
aujourd'hui aux familles des victimes et
aux blessés
certains groupes terroristes en
Palestine et ailleurs ont de plus
célébré cette attaque dans une posture
de haine méprisable qui ne résoudra rien
au contraire
semaine après semaine nous assistons en
Israël et dans les Territoires occupés à
une très grave escalade des tensions on
ne compte plus les actes de violence et
les victimes pour suivre la trajectoire
actuelle ne peut mener qu'à davantage
d'affrontements davantage de haine
davantage de souffrance il est
indispensable d'infléchir cette
trajectoire la France réitère donc
qu'elle est déterminée à oeuvrer à la
paix sur la base de droit international
et sur la base de la solution à deux
états la seule qui permettra aux
Israéliens et aux Palestiniens de vivre
en paix et en sécurité comme ils en ont
le droit
ce message constant de la France
Monsieur le député le président de la
République le répétera au Premier
ministre israélien qu'il recevra jeudi
soir vous le savez et je le porterai
aussi auprès d'autres pays de la région
dans lesquels je me rendrai cette
semaine il est urgent
urgent autant que nécessaire de
restaurer un horizon politique cette
horizon qui manque aujourd'hui
cruellement je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la ministre
la parole est à Madame ma Street
Panossian Bouvet pour le groupe
Renaissance
ici cette question s'adresse à Madame la
Ministre Isabelle Rome madame la
ministre avec mes collègues nous saluons
le lancement du plan national de lutte
contre le racisme l'antisémitisme et les
discrimination il y a l'origine lancé
par la première ministre que vous avez
la magnifique mission de conduire le 20
janvier dernier le Conseil scientifique
de la dilkra la Délégation
interministérielle à la lutte contre le
racisme l'antisémitisme et l'homophobie
a été dissout par sa déléguée ce conseil
composé d'universitaires avaient pour
objet d'éclairer les politiques mises en
place par la dilkra il a été traversé
depuis mai 2022 par de multiples
tensions sur les questions de
transidentité liée à l'appartenance de
son président à l'Observatoire de la
petite sirène association jugée
transphobes par certains membres du
conseil scientifique qui a été fondée
par Céline Masson et Carole Caroline
eliasf psychanalyste qui dénonce
régulièrement les dérives potentielles
du trans genvisme chez les mineurs
s'il est tout à fait possible d'être en
désaccord avec les positions de cette
observatoire il ne semble pas que le
débat est vraiment eu lieu la délégué de
la dilkra ayant même porté sans succès
d'ailleurs sur le terrain pénal en les
signalant au parquet lacusation de
transphobie donc font l'objet les deux
psychanalystes est lourde or elle
soulève un problème spécifique qui est
celui des mineurs doit-on considérer le
désir de transition d'un enfant comme
indiscutable au point d'accéder à une
demande de médialisation aux
conséquences potentiellement
irréversibles ou bien mettons des
conditions c'est tout le débat au nom de
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant principe
à valeur constitutionnelle et enfin
cette dissolution interroge aussi sur le
respect des libertés académiques et plus
largement sur la protection de la
liberté d'expression donc pouvez-vous
nous éclairer madame la mini sur cette
dissolution et nous comptons sur vous
pour que le combat déterminé contre le
racisme l'antisémitisme et la haine LGBT
vous voyez dans ce plan national puis se
poursuivre dans la cohérence avec notre
idéal républicain et universaliste merci
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
Isabelle Rome ministre délégué chargé de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
de la diversité de l'égalité des chances
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée vous m'interrogez sur un grand
sujet qui nous tient particulièrement à
coeur et sur lequel nous concentrons
toute notre énergie c'est celui de la
lutte contre le racisme
l'antisémitisme et les discriminations
il nous revient de les traquer
inlassablement car ils entaillent notre
pacte social fondé sur l'universalisme
universalisme républicain et donc
humanisme
madame la députée pas un universalisme
dévoyé qui l'existence d'un monde
pluriel
l'universalisme auquel nous aspirons et
celui qui offre à chacune et chacun la
dignité qui lui revient la première
ministre a présenté hier un plan de 80
mesures concrètes que je suis fière de
piloter aux côtés des ministres et d'une
majorité engagée rapidement maintenant
sur la question de la dissolution du
conseil scientifique que vous évoquez il
ne reposait sur aucun cas juridique
n'était encadré ni dans sa composition
ni dans ses missions force est de
constater qu'il ne produisait plus grand
chose depuis plusieurs mois dans la
lutte face à notre ennemi commun seul
l'efficacité importe
c'est donc pour nous appuyer plus
efficacement sur la communauté
scientifique que nous avons choisie de
renouveler les modalités de travail avec
les chercheurs dans la diversité des
expertises est une ressource précieuse
nous avons la même ambition pour le
futur plan de lutte contre la haine anti
LGBT plus face au N je serai toujours un
traitable face à toutes les haines
racismes antisémitisme homophobie
transphobie pas de hiérarchie entre les
haines vous pouvez compter sur ma
détermination pour les combattre sans
relâche merci madame la ministre
la parole est à Madame Marie-France
l'euro pour le gros rassemblement
national
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à Madame le Premier ministre
madame vous avez qualifié votre réforme
de réforme de justice selon le nouvel
âge légal de 64 ans qu'elle introduit
que répondez-vous à tous les salariés
qui atteindront leur 43 annuités à 62
ans et qui devront travailler deux ans
de plus que les autres en fait ce sont
aussi les maires de famille les ouvriers
les employés et tous les travailleurs de
seconde ligne qui sont souvent des
femmes qui devront travailler deux ans
de plus vous avez également qualifié
votre réforme de réforme de progrès or
vous faites peser l'essentiel des
efforts sur la classe moyenne en quoi et
sans progrès plus les débats avancent
plus les Français découvrent la réalité
de votre réforme et assez logiquement
plus ils y sont opposés
les manifestations du jour
complémentaires de l'opposition que nous
députés de divers bancs menant ici
illustre bien cette opposition
grandissante nous comprenons que vous
n'êtes pas très à l'aise car le rap
comme le rappelle le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites ce ne sont
pas les dépenses de retraite qui posent
problème mais bien les recettes
conséquences directes de vos politiques
et comme si cela ne suffisait pas après
avoir délocalisé l'industrie française
et ses emplois après avoir détruit la
productivité basse de notre modèle de
retraite par répartition le gouvernement
continue de tirer les salaires vers le
bas avec le futur texte sur
l'immigration et son titre de séjour
métier en tension aggravant la
paupérisation de notre pays et de nos
travailleurs puisque nous avons appris
il y a quelques jours deux chiffres
illustrant votre politique migratoire en
2022 les motifs économiques sont en
hausse de plus de 45%, et les
régularisations de sans-papiers en
hausse de 8%
madame au lieu de servir les desiderata
de la Commission européenne et derrière
le lobby des fonds de pension
pourriez-vous s'il vous plaît écouter
l'appel à l'aide des Français en leur
imperiant cette réforme je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du socle ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion
la première ministre et le gouvernement
sur la réforme des retraites et sur le
relèvement progressif de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits de 62 64 ans
est-ce que c'est un effort oui c'est un
effort qui est demandé aux Français pour
garantir la pérennité du système du
système par répartition c'est un effort
de travail supplémentaire et l'objectif
que nous poursuivons depuis le début des
concertations avec la première ministre
et faire en sorte que cette effort soit
le plus justement répartie vous avez
dans votre question évoquer un point
particulier qui est la durée de
cotisation et vous avez évoqué une
génération en disant mais que
répondez-vous à celles et ceux qui au
moment où ils atteindront l'âge légal
auront cotisé peut-être plus longtemps
que la durée exigée c'est une situation
que nous connaissons déjà madame la
députée aujourd'hui dans le système tel
que nous le connaissons chaque année
nous avons 800 000 départs à la retraite
sur ces 800 000 départs à la retraite
180 000 assurés ont un nombre de
trimestres un nombre d'années supérieur
à ce qui est requis et lorsque nous nous
retournons quelque peu sur le temps et
sur le passé avant 2003 avant la
création des carrières longues là je
vais pars à la retraite était fixé à 60
ans la durée de cotisations à 37 ans et
demi ce qui commençaient leur carrière à
23 ans par thé autour de 60 ans et demi
en ayant travaillé exactement le temps
requis et puis ce qui commençaient à 15
ans à 14 ans travailler 45 ou 46 ans
pour avoir droit au départ à la retraite
à 60 ans de la même manière les
carrières longues ont permis d'amortir
de diminuer cet écart et depuis chaque
réforme a permis de diminuer l'écart
entre le minimum de cotisations requis
et la durée de cotisation effectuée par
un certain nombre d'assurés il y a
parfois dans le débat une tentation ou
une facilité et je ne lis pas par
rapport à votre question qui
consisterait à imaginer que la durée de
cotisation requise est un plafond en
réalité c'est un plancher c'est un
plancher parce que dans notre système
depuis qu'il a été créé la durée de
cotisation pour avoir droit à taux plein
est une durée planché et nous avons je
le disais maintenant un quart des
assurés qui travaillent déjà plus que
cette durée de cotisation cela fait
partie de ce système là tout ce que nous
avons fait avec la première ministre
c'est de réduire un même les cartes pour
établir un maximum d'égalité
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Delphine lingman
pour le groupe démocrate
madame madame la Présidente chère
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires je
souhaite y associer ma collègue Laurence
Vichy ainsi que les parlementaires du
Puy-de-Dôme et l'association Objectif
capital le prochain rapport du coi
Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures présidé par notre
collègue David Valence sur la période
2023 2032 est très attendu à tel point
que certains extraits sont des déjà
connus
l'Auvergne et le territoire
métropolitain le plus mal relié à la
capitale sur le plan ferroviaire 3h30
3h30 pour relier clairement à Paris
quand tout va bien en effet de
nombreuses défaillances techniques liées
au vieillissement du matériel roulant et
des infrastructures provoque des retards
fréquents soulevant la colère des
usagers victimes de décennies de
sous-investissement structurels et de
promesses d'investissement non tenus
l'axe ferroviaire Clermont Paris fait
pourtant partie des trois lignes tu
rentres des trains d'équilibre des
territoires
l'État s'est engagé financièrement à
hauteur de 760 millions d'euros jusqu'en
2026 mais pour diverses raisons des
retards sont pris sur la régénération de
leur ligne et les livraisons de
nouvelles rames agir au plus tôt pour
garantir une ligne de qualité durable et
efficace est une question de survie pour
notre territoire d'autant plus que selon
le rapport du coi l'engagement de l'État
semblerait se terminer en 2026 or nous
avons besoin de poursuivre les
investissements pour moderniser la ligne
et faire passer le temps de trajet à
2h30 la grande vertu du rapport du coi
sera de mettre sur table une liste de
priorités et une nouvelle programmation
avait ainsi déclaré le ministre des
Transports le 5 octobre dernier au Sénat
mais question sont simples est-ce que la
ligne structurante Clermont Paris fait
partie des priorités de l'État au-delà
de 2026 est-elle inscrite dans un
programme de modernisation enfin si tel
est le cas pouvez-vous vous apporter des
éléments de précision je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
j'ai le plaisir de vous répondre en
l'absence de Clément bun que vous aviez
interpellé d'abord pour vous rappeler
mais vous le savez que le 24 février
dans quelques jours le comité annuel de
suivi à se réunir à nouveau et que
désormais un comité régulier de suivi
pas seulement tous les ans mais qui
associe l'ensemble des parlementaires
des départements traversés existent et
qu'après une visite à Clermont une
visite à Vichy pour faire en sorte de
d'en coordonner l'ensemble des actions
Clément bon a précisément pris
l'engagement de vous tenir régulièrement
informé de là où nous en sommes par
rapport au retard que vous évoquez c'est
un milliard 100 millions d'euros à la
minute où nous parlons qui sont
globalement prévus pour le soutien à la
régénération et à l'amélioration du
confort des usagers les rames elles ont
vocation à tout être livré en 2026 avec
la première qui arrivera à la première
nouvelle rame qui arrivera en
circulation dès 2025
malgré les incidents liés à ces retards
de régénération la fréquentation la
régularité c'est améliorée sur le
premier semestre nous sommes à 86%
contre 78 sur le semestre précédent mais
évidemment ce sont ces travaux de
régénération qui permettront d'être
enfin à l'échelle de la ligne
structurante que vous évoquez qui figure
dans ce
à ce titre là dans la carte ferroviaire
que nous avons vous avez évoqué le
rapport du comité d'orientation des
infrastructures et le travail piloté en
particulier par votre collègue le député
David Valence sa remise dans les
prochains jours et imminente et
permettra à ce moment-là d'expliquer la
méthodologie et le suivi avec lequel le
gouvernement entend y répondre il vous a
pas échappé si vous en avez lu quelques
feuilles qui à l'intérieur des
propositions qui sont structurantes une
ambition qui est cohérente avec la
transition écologique et avec le besoin
de proximité des territoires et de faire
en sorte de les rapprocher et
d'améliorer leur confort
monsieur
tout le monde
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'économie ce premier
février les péages d'autoroute vont
augmenter de près de 5 % face à ce
raquette les gilets jaunes de Lyon font
aujourd'hui une opération péage gratuite
et je l'ai soutient pour reprendre les
mots de la CGT énergie de Marseille
c'est illégal mais c'est moral en effet
selon le Canard Enchaîné un rapport vous
a été remis il y a deux ans il
préconisait de baisser les prix des
péages de 60% vous l'avez gardé secret
monsieur le ministre vous avez déclaré
au MEDEF un super profit je ne sais pas
ce que c'est voici ce que c'est en 2021
ces sociétés d'autoroute ont réalisé
3,9 milliards d'euros de profits que
font ces entreprises de ces supers
profits augmentent-elles les salaires
non elle donne tout aux actionnaires 3,3
milliards en 2021 soit 85% des bénéfices
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a donc raison oui
accumuler ces milliards sur le dos des
Français est immoral oui
les actionnaires sont des parasites
aussi Monsieur le Ministre voici mes
trois questions premièrement vous
engagez-vous à rendre public le rapport
sur les sociétés d'autoroute que vous
gardez secrets deuxièmement avez-vous
personnellement ou parmi les membres de
votre gouvernement des conflits
d'intérêts avec ces entreprises qui
expliqueraient un tel laxisme enfin
allez vous faire cesser le raquette des
automobilistes trois questions monsieur
le ministre et un conseil
renationaliser les autoroutes comme le
proposait Jean-Luc Mélenchon
77% des Français ils sont favorables
faites respecter enfin l'intérêt général
et la volonté du peuple contre l'intérêt
privé et l'égoïsme des riches
je vous remercie la parole est à
Christophe bécheux ministre la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
j'ai bien noté que votre question
s'adressait à Bruno Le Maire
je vais vous apporter la réponse au
sujet que vous évoquez d'abord oui le
premier février conformément au close
qui sont prévues dans les contrats il y
aura une augmentation des péages puisque
ces contrats prévoient une indexation
sur l'inflation qui n'est pas totalement
répercuté à la fois compte tenu de ce
que le Gouvernement a souhaité et même
une clause différentielle pour que les
véhicules électriques ne voient non
seulement pas les pièges augmentés mais
diminuer puisque ce sera 5% de baisse au
titre de la transition écologique mais
j'ai bien compris que l'essentiel de
votre question n'était pas là dessus
et c'est ce la raison pour laquelle ce
rapport avait été demandé c'est de faire
en sorte d'obtenir davantage de
fiscalité de la part des autoroutes à la
minute où nous nous parlons nous avons
deux contentieux pendant devant les
tribunaux 1 sur l'indexation de la taxe
d'aménagement du territoire pour lequel
nous avons gagné une première manche le
13 janvier dernier devant le tribunal
administratif et la deuxième sur la taxe
exceptionnelle sur les contributions
autoroutières dans ce contexte ce
rapport il sert à préparer à accompagner
les arguments du gouvernement il est
donc couvert par le contentieux en cours
et c'est ce qui explique qu'il n'est pas
été publié l'enjeu pour nous c'est au
contraire d'aller chercher l'argent dans
le cadre de ces profits qui sont
importants avec une obsession qui est la
fin des concessions quand vous dites que
la solution serait de nationaliser les
autoroutes ça veut dire que vous
souhaitez qu'on mette 40 milliards
d'euros d'argent public pour acheter des
autoroutes et ensuite faire en sorte que
nous finanions la route ça n'est pas
comme ça qu'il faut procéder au titre de
la transition écologique il faut au
contraire faire en sorte de prélever de
l'argent sur les autoroutes pour être
capable de financer le report modal et
en particulier sur le ferroviaire les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute
sont les premières contributrices de la
fille de France à ce titre je vous
remercie monsieur léoman et bien
monsieur le ministre vous devriez suivre
les recommandations du rapport alors
récupérer le contrôle des autoroutes dès
2026 ou t'accélère à 63%, voilà ce qu'il
faut faire là vous êtes en train
d'attendre vous rendez l'état impuissant
monsieur le ministre un peu de bonne
volonté les françaises font racketter il
y en a ras-le-bol merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Henri
alfonsdari pour le groupe horizon merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse alors que les arbitrages
relatifs au moyen d'enseignement
occupent activement les services de
l'éducation nationale les suppressions
de poste à venir pour la rentrée
prochaine sont une source d'angoisse
pour les communautés éducatives rurales
en effet ces suppressions de pose
viennent percuter les efforts conduits
par les collectivités rurales et les
services déconcentrés de votre ministère
le stade expérimental des territoires
éducatifs ruraux qui ne concernent
aujourd'hui que trois académies les
suppressions de moyens d'enseignement et
les réalités en matière de mobilité pour
les enseignants et les familles sur nos
territoires interrogent en effet nous ne
pouvons pas faire disparaître nos
ruralités ces ruralités qui se
renouvellent toujours davantage dans
leur mode d'organisation pour répondre
aux non-veux défis qui se présentent à
elle l'école est au cœur de
préoccupations des élus ruraux elle est
souvent la colonne vertébrale des
politiques qu'il déploient au service de
la cohésion et de l'attractivité de leur
territoire surtout enfin l'école rurale
est un levier essentiel pour accompagner
l'égalité des chances que vous portez et
pour permettre aux enfants et aux
familles de construire sereinement leur
avenir
ainsi Monsieur le Ministre ne serait-il
pas temps de réaliser un certain nombre
de critères qui conduisent aux
fermetures de classe notamment le
critère de nombre d'élèves par cléla
sanalysé je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
papendaille ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse
[Musique]
les territoires ruraux ne sont pas
traités de la même manière nous tenons
compte du fait que les services publics
ne sont pas disposés de la même manière
et nous prêtons une attention
particulière alors situation les dazen
néanmoins sont parfois obligés de
regrouper plusieurs niveaux dans les
mêmes classes tout en veillant à
maintenir le chiffre d'environ 24 élèves
ou moins par classe pour les grandes
sections les CP les CE1 enfin à ce stade
nous en sommes encore au début des
évaluations du processus pour la rentrée
2023 et je sais que vous êtes en lien
régulier avec le dazen de votre
département c'est un dialogue qui se
construit des évolutions vont encore se
faire sentir d'ici au mois de juin et à
la fin août nous sommes donc
actuellement dans un processus rien
n'est définitif et le diagogue avec les
élus locaux et maintenu je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Sandrine Rousseau
pour le groupe écologiste
madame la Première ministre j'étais tout
à l'heure Place d'Italie dans ma
circonscription et il y avait beaucoup
de monde vraiment vraiment beaucoup de
monde alors bien sûr j'ai discuté avec
les gens là-bas et il est elle avait des
questions pour vous alors je voulais
livre comme ça parce qu'elles étaient
intéressantes ces questions d'ailleurs
ça vaudrait le coup je vous assure que
vous les entendiez que vous les écoutiez
même que vous y répondiez parce que vous
savez ce que c'est cette sagesse de la
rue c'est un vrai truc alors je vais
commencer par Lisa elle avait cette
question pour vous je cite croyez-vous
vraiment que les gens de plus de 55 ans
au RSA retrouveront du travail pour
cotiser bien sûr je précise elle ne
parlait pas des 15 à 20h de travail
gratuit obligatoire que vous imposez
mais d'un vrai travail avec un vrai
salaire ensuite il y avait pierre sa
question était la suivante pourquoi ce
serait aux petites gens de payer pour
que les retraites soient à l'équilibre
ah bah bonne question ensuite Thomas
avez-vous repéré madame la Première
ministre que dans un système comptable
il y avait des dépenses mais aussi aussi
des recettes faut dire que Thomas était
économiste alors forcément
Robin ensuite je fais mes études mais au
rythme où ça va j'ai peur de mourir
avant ma retraite pourquoi ne pas
prendre l'argent là où il est
Karine elle se demandait pourquoi le
gouvernement dit-il que ce truc se fait
pour l'intérêt de tous alors que ça
touche uniquement les plus précaires les
carrières hachées et les carrières
longues ensuite si le cola au sujet du
handicap parce que les RQTH seront
concernés aussi par les trimestres
supplémentaires Maryse et ton censé
mourir au travail Nathalie elle demande
comment sont comptés les années de
travail des sans-papiers ce n'est pas
précisé dans ce projet Lila quand est-ce
qu'on arrête les 49-3 Valérie je n'ai
pas envie de travailler jusqu'à 64 ans
comment fait-on lenca je suis médecin en
retraite et c'est pour mes patients que
je suis là et tous les troubles
musculo-squelettiques que j'ai soigné
que vont-ils devenir
Marie-Pierre 83 ans voulait que vous
souveniez qu'avant vous étiez socialiste
pourquoi avoir tant changé Saïd pompier
professionnel
s'il vous plaît
c'est fini
[Musique]
un peu de silence s'il vous plaît la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier du stop
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion merci madame la
présidente madame la députée Rousseau je
note que vous avez besoin qu'on vous
aide à poser vos questions
je note que vous avez besoin que vous
aide à poser vos questions et je note
dans les questions que vous faites mine
de relayer ici qu'en réalité vous ne
faites Quico ou des informations au fake
news au mensonge que vous ne cessez de
proférer sur le système de retraite je
note je note un échec je note une
différence entre nous madame Rousseau je
note une différence entre nous et entre
les bancs entre vous
je note mais je suis sûr que Madame
rousseau va prendre plaisir à écouter la
fin de ma question ma femme ma réponse
pardonnez-moi je note une grande
différence entre vous et les banques
cette majorité cette différence elle ne
tient en un mot responsabilité
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur
s'il vous plaît
la parole est à Monsieur kevin fait
faire pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre combe maltraitance par
négligence rationnement de la nourriture
et des équipements de soins manque de
personnel détournement de fonds publics
il y a un an éclaté le scandale de la
gestion de nos EHPAD avec ORPEA au banc
des accusés les membres du gouvernement
et les députés de la majorité défilaient
alors sur les plateaux l'arme aux yeux
mains sur le cœur pour nous promettre
qu'il y aurait un avant et un après mais
de l'aveu du président de l'Observatoire
du grand âge en un an rien n'a changé
les contrôles sont faits à la va-vite
bref rien de nouveau pour nos anciens
toujours en grande difficulté vous avez
annoncé que les inspections autrefois
faites tous les 20 à 30 ans devrait
couvrir les 7500 établissements français
d'ici 2024 mais avec seulement 18%
contrôlés à ce jour l'objectif ne sera
pas tenu pire il n'existe toujours aucun
référentiel comme base de contrôle et le
syndicat des directeurs d'Ehpad fait ce
terrible constat le plus souvent on nous
demande d'envoyer par email des
documents compt et administratif alors
que la maltraitance continue vous avez
tous refusé il y a quelques jours une
proposition de loi de bon sens présenté
par notre collègue La Valette permettant
d'étendre le droit de visite des
parlementaires notamment dans nos EHPAD
le taux d'encadrement moyen de trois
soignants pour 10 résidents est au
centre du problème dans son rapport
publié mi-janvier la Défenseur des
droits réaffirme qu'en dessous de 8
encadrants pour 10 résidences malgré
toute la bonne volonté et la
bienveillance de nos soignants on ne
peut pas travailler sans maltraitance et
ça n'est pas le plfs 2023 qui ouvre 3000
recrutements alors qu'il en faudrait 20
000 en urgence qui résoudra ce problème
alors Monsieur le Ministre combien de
lanceurs d'alerte combien de
signalements par plateforme numérique et
combien de rapports vous faudra-t-il
encore la loi sur le grand âge se fait
attendre depuis 25 ans ma question est
simple quand est-ce que nos aînés seront
enfin mieux considérés
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Christophe
qu'on ministre des Solidarités de
l'autonomie des personnes handicapées
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
PFR vous l'avez rappelé il y a un an la
publication des fossoyeurs a provoqué un
choc de conscience chez l'ensemble de
nos compatriotes ce choc a été terrible
et il a été suivi d'une réponse
puissante de la part des pouvoirs
publics une réponse puissante pour
éradiquer de nos établissements de nos
EHPAD mais aussi des activités à
domicile des actes scandaleux qui ont
été à nouveau rappelés il y a quelques
jours dans un certain nombre de
reportages cette réponse puissante elle
est passée d'abord par une série de
contrôles de contrôle de l'ensemble de
nos EHPAD 400 EHPAD ont été contrôlés
immédiatement après le choc et la
publication des fossoyeurs plus de 1400
ont été contrôlés à ce jour et je peux
vous confirmer que le 7500 que compte
notre pays le seront d'ici à la fin de
l'année 2024 ces contrôles ont donné
lieu et bien à des réponses fortes plus
de 1800 injonctions 11 saisines du
procureur de la République il faut
maintenant que les choses s'accélèrent
pour faire en sorte que les choses
changent de façon concrète dans
l'ensemble de nos EHPAD je l'ai dit j'ai
fait la question de la lutte contre la
maltraitance dans les établissements une
des priorités de mon action je lancerai
dans quelques jours les états généraux
de la lutte contre la maltraitance pour
réunir l'ensemble des parties prenantes
ainsi qu'une plateforme de signalement
parce qu'il est important il est
important comme l’ont fait les lanceurs
d'alerte que la parole puisse se libérer
dans les établissements et que les
familles puissent signaler l'ensemble de
ces maltraitances et c'est ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui après pour faire face
au vieillissement de la population notre
pays doit aujourd'hui s'organiser grâce
notamment au 9 milliards d'euros qui
sont inscrits dans la trajectoire de la
branche autonomie grâce aussi au
lancement du recrutement de 50
professionnels soignants dans nos EHPAD
pour les 5 ans qui viennent grâce aussi
au nombre de places qui sera augmentée
dans les services de soins infirmiers à
domicile
la parole est à Monsieur Lefèvre pour le
groupe Renaissance merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des outre-mer et j'y associe ma collègue
Caroline Adam monsieur le ministre
demain la ville de Lyon s'apprêtait à
accueillir à l'initiative de son maire
Grégory Doucet le sinistre personnage de
Salah Amaury à l'occasion d'une
conférence sur les accords d'Oslo
d'autres villes de Gennevilliers à
Aubervilliers n'hésite pas non plus à
mettre à l'honneur un individu qui a été
reconnu coupable d'appartenance une
entreprise collective en vue de
commettre des actions terroristes sur le
territoire israélien ce renoncement
salutaire nous le devons à des héros
comme Claude Bloch dernier rescapé
d'Auschwitz vivant à Lyon qui a tourné
le dos à la représentante du maire pour
protester contre sa venue
si la France a condamné son expulsion
par l'État d'Israël et défend son droit
à un procès équitable sa participation à
ce simulacre de conférence aurait été un
scandale oui suite était un scandale que
de prendre prétexte d'une
pseudo-conférence universitaire pour
réhabiliter un homme condamné par l'État
d'Israël pour sa tentative sa
participation à la tentative
d'assassinat du grand rabbin Ovadia
Youssef suite été un scandale parce que
l'on ne met pas impunément à l'honneur
un homme dont les liens avec une
organisation classée comme terroriste
par l'Union européenne sont avérées
cette banalisation de la haine était là
ce que le dernier épisode d'une
tentative de réhabilitation de cet
individu par une partie de cette
hémicycle qui dans l'indécence la plus
totale à oserait comparer son
extradition à une déportation n’hésitant
pas à l'acclamer à sa descente d'avion
ou alors recevoir au sein de notre
institution la déshonorant de sa
présence ma question est donc simple
monsieur le ministre quelle mesure le
gouvernement compte-t-il prendre afin de
protéger les Français en général et les
citoyens juifs en particulier des
actions qu'ils pourraient entreprendre
sur le sol français comme de l'apologie
de la haine qu'il pourrait y diffusé je
vous remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente dedans et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Lefebvre vous avez raison heureusement
que Monsieur le Maire de Lyon a renoncé
à la mise à l'honneur et à la mise à
participation de cette triste
personnalité je crois à la fois que les
appels de sa propre population notamment
lors de la commémoration de ce weekend
comme vous l'avez très bien dit mais
également de la représentante de l'étape
puisque ma demande la préfète de la
Région Rhône-Alpes a évoqué avec le
maire de Lyon que si jamais cette
conférence était maintenue elle serait
proposée être interdite par l'étape pour
menaces à l'ordre public il est heureux
que le maire de Lyon ait renoncé à son
projet mortifère parce qu'il ne peut pas
y avoir il ne peut y avoir en aucun cas
un doute sur la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme dans notre pays je veux
je veux également souligner votre action
monsieur député comme président
désormais du groupe de l'action contre
l'anti sémitisme mais je veux dire
qu'avec le travail que font les forces
de l'ordre les préfets de la République
mais aussi des associations c'est un
quart d'acte antisémite en moins qui a
eu lieu dans l'année 2022 cependant il
ne faut pas crier victoire puisque
encore 430 actes antisémites ont eu lieu
en 2022 des insultes des attaques
physiques des attaques contre des lieux
de culte contre des écoles
confessionnelles et vous le savez
d'innombrables insultes et ignoministes
des réseaux sociaux devant la
mobilisation de toute la France parce
que près de l'antisémitisme c'est le
problème de tous les Français et pas
simplement de nos concitoyens Juifs 1500
cyber patrouilleurs seront au
rendez-vous de la loi de modernisation
de mystère que vous avez voté c'est
aussi le cas d'ouverture désormais 24
heures sur 24 de Pharos qui permet de
signaler la haine en ligne et bien
évidemment la protection de tous les
lieux de culte Juifs de leur lieu
communautaire et des écoles qui ont
malheureusement connu vous le savez le
terrorisme des années précédentes je
sais que votre bureau c'est le terrain
monsieur le député aidez-nous à
travailler ensemble contre
l'antisémitisme merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Mansour
camardine pour le groupe les républicain
merci madame la Présidente
madame la Première ministre
les présidents ont exprimé leur volonté
d'accompagner le gouvernement dans une
réforme de retraite qui soit juste en
particulier pour le petit retraites
si le gouvernement si pour le
gouvernement la réforme juste concerne
le territoire métropolitain pour le
groupe LR la réforme juste concerne
aussi les ultramans or les ultramarins
partent en moyenne plus tard en retraite
perçoivent des pensions plus faibles et
meurent plus jeunes
encore sur cette territoire la retraite
moyenne et pour une carrière complète et
de moins 20% en dessous de la moyenne
nationale et le taux de grandes
propriétés de retraités et 13 fois
supérieure à celui de métropole
pire encore à Mayotte la pension moyenne
est de 276 euros alors que la location
de solidarité pour les personnes âgées
et plafonnées pour des raisons que
j'ignore à 50% des selles de droit
commun la réforme des retraites et donc
une occasion à saisir pour améliorer
deux situations spécifiques le système
de retraite à Mayotte et les petits
traités agricoles outre-mer notamment
aux Antilles c'est pourquoi le groupe R
vous propose de mettre en place
outre-mer un dispositif de rachat de
trimestre à un prix raisonnable pour les
agriculteurs et les travailleurs
agricoles ultramarins de supprimer sans
délai la discrimination de la décote de
50% de l'espace à Mayotte et de porter
la pension moyenne à Mayotte au moins de
276 à 400 euros aussi je vous demande
madame la Premier ministre de dire les
initiatives que vous envisagez de
prendre pour répondre à nos propositions
et améliorer l'essor de retraités
outre-mer
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft au
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Député camardine
vous évoquez la situation des retraites
d'outre-mer et vous avez raison de
souligner combien ces régimes ou plutôt
ce régime ainsi appliqué votre mère crée
des différences il y a plusieurs aspects
dans votre question il y a d'abord la
question des salariés de l'agriculture
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire que nous
avons un défi qui est de faire en sorte
que au-delà de du régime général la mise
en place du régime complémentaire agir
Carco pour les salariés du secteur de
l'agriculture doit être une priorité
mais cette priorité relève de la
discussion entre les partenaires sociaux
puisque ce sont eux qui assurent la
gouvernance d'agir Carco nous pouvons y
travailler ensemble à la fois pour un
travail de conviction et faire en sorte
que ces salariés de l'agriculture dans
le domaine dans les territoires
d'outre-mer puissent être mieux couverts
et justement couvert vous avez aussi
évoqué la question des retraités à
Mayotte vous savez mieux que personne
monsieur le député que la situation que
nous connaissons à Mayotte est très
caractéristique un troisième obligatoire
qui n'existe que depuis 1987 l'absence
de régime complémentaire obligatoire une
durée de cotisation constatée qui est
particulièrement en bas c'est
aujourd'hui nous n'avons que 2500
bénéficiaires du système de retraite
pour un montant de retraite vous l'avez
dit de 287 euros ce qui est extrêmement
bas il y a un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui ont été adaptés à la
fois par minoration vous avez évoqué la
question de la SPA mais aussi par un
mode de calcul parfois un peu plus
favorable pour l'accès à un certain
nombre de prestations notamment en
validant d'office un certain nombre de
trimestres entre 1997 et 2002 il y a
aussi une période de convergence vous le
savez notamment sur les questions de
cotisation et du nombre de trimestres
requis jusqu'en 2023 pour une partie
jusqu'en 2036 pour l'autre dans le cadre
du projet de loi que nous avons présenté
avec la première ministre la question de
Mayotte n'est pas traitée de manière
particulière elle n'apparaît pas puisque
nous avons fait le choix de ne pas
appliquer la réforme telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui au territoire Mayotte cela
ne signifie pas que nous ne devons pas
travailler et d'ici l'examen du texte je
vous propose que nous puissions avec
tous les parlementaires de Mayotte voir
comment nous pouvons améliorer cette
situation la rendre plus juste mieux
protéger les retraités et faire en sorte
que cette convergence puisse être
accélérée à l'occasion d'une
revalorisation mais aussi d'une
amélioration des conditions de gestion
des retraites sur Mayotte merci Monsieur
le Ministre quelques secondes si vous
voulez monsieur camardine 7 secondes
exactement
pour y travailler pendant ce débat parce
que ça ne peut pas être après quand nous
avons fait beaucoup de promesses des
promesses qui n'ont jamais été tenues
depuis au moins 15 ans
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Aurélie trouvée pour le groupe la France
insoumise
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre
avant que vous partiez c'est une journée
historique de celle qui redonne au
peuple sa puissance nous sommes des
millions dans la rue et la colère monte
encore contre votre réforme madame la
Première ministre vous rabâchez cette
réforme n'est plus négociable vous
pariez donc sur le passage en force
contre la vie de l'immense majorité des
Français contre tous les syndicats de
salariés passage en force en étouffant
la démocratie parlementaire par un 49-3
déguisé et comme vous n'avez plus
d'arguments valables vous tombez dans la
Grosse fierté l'insulte votre Ministre
de l'Intérieur envoie les opposants de
la réforme au roi fainéant mais à qui
parlez-vous ainsi à tous les
travailleurs essentiels qui tiennent ce
pays depuis deux ans vous n'avez pas
compris c'est la France du travail qui
est dans la rue celle du travail qui use
ceux qui se lèvent à 4h du matin à Bondy
pour faire le ménage des bureaux de la
défense des 7 heures celles qui nous
pourra pas tenir deux ans de plus
nous aimons le travail mais le travail
dignement rémunéré le travail qui
redonne du sens le travail qui offre une
retraite heureuse
mais c'est vrai nous n'aimons pas le
travail exploiter celui qui nourrit les
profits des actionnaires et c'est bien
pour ça que nous n'aimons pas votre
réforme vous nous dites la grève est
irresponsable vous n'avez sans doute
jamais fait grève moi oui savez-vous ce
que c'est de perdre une journée de
salaire la grève des travailleurs c'est
un choix responsable et grave
par votre acharnement vous produisez le
chaos c'est vous et vous seul qui est
responsable du blocage du pays car le
peuple car le peuple résiste et refuse
d'être écrasé une fois de plus vous êtes
seul et nous sommes des millions alors
jusqu'où irez-vous pour imposer votre
projet funeste
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci
la députée trouvée
de mots mais vous le savez je l'ai déjà
dit mais comme votre argumentaire n'est
pas nouveau ma réponse ne sera pas
nécessairement nouvelle cette réforme
elle est nécessaire elle est nécessaire
parce que le système est
structurellement déficitaire je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure ce sont 150 milliards
d'euros de déficits cumulés sur les 10
années qui viennent c'est d'un fils
annuel de 12,5 milliards d'euros par an
2027 c'est demain c'est un déficit
annuel de 20 milliards d'euros en 2035
c'est demain et nous avons la volonté de
cet effort nous demandons aux Français
soit le plus justement réparti nous le
faisons avec l'aménagement des carrières
longues nous le faisons avec la prise en
compte de la pénibilité bien longue bien
nombreux parmi les exemples que vous
avez cités sont ceux qui vont pouvoir
bénéficier à la fois de l'amélioration
du compte professionnel de prévention
mais aussi de la meilleure prise en
compte des critères ergonomiques sur les
postures pénibles sur les vibration sur
le port de charge lourdes bien nombreux
parmi celles et ceux que vous avez vous
avez cités sont ceux qui vont bénéficier
du relèvement de retraite minimum il y a
dans la réforme que nous portons madame
la députée des progrès des progrès
sociaux et qui sont aussi une manière
d'accompagner les fortes demandées en
français ne sortez pas de la vérité de
cette réforme dites qu'elle contient
également véritablement plutôt
qu'essayer de la déformer et de faire
peur aux gens cette réforme je le dis
elle est nécessaire est juste et c'est
pour ça que nous allons la mener
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame trouvé 5 secondes je réponds vous
voyez vous voyez monsieur le ministre
vous pensez avoir raison comme
d'habitude contre tout le monde mais
tout le pays est debout et tout le pays
sera debout demain mais c'est ce qui
vous fera perdre
la parole est à monsieur Guillaume
Garraud pour le groupe socialiste merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre du Travail aujourd'hui les
Français se mobilisent massivement à
Paris à Marseille à Laval à Toulouse à
Maubeuge il se mobilise massivement et
partout en France pour dire non à la
réforme des retraites que vous voulez
imposer
massivement et encore plus nombreux que
le 19 janvier
c'est une protestation de grande ampleur
qui vient des profondeurs de notre pays
parce que elles touchent à l'idée même
que les Français se font de la justice
car ils ont bien compris les Français
qu'avec les 64 ans c'était les ouvriers
les employés les salariés qui ont fait
des études courtes qui devront faire les
plus grands sacrifices et que les femmes
en particulier
allaient être pénalisé selon les mots
d'un ministre du gouvernement alors
monsieur le ministre du Travail pour ne
pas
brutaliser notre pays pour ne pas le
fracturer davantage pour ne pas ajouter
l'injustice aux inégalités quand
allez-vous retirer votre réforme
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du stop ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre garrot vous ne vous
interrogez sur le sens de la réforme
quelle note j'ai eu l'occasion d'y
répondre vous nous interrogez en
particulier sur la question de celles et
ceux qui commencent à travailler tout le
dispositif que nous mettons en place
d'un dispositif qui permet justement de
mieux protéger celles et ceux qui
commencent à travailler tout dans le
système que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
système que nous connaissons et qui se
caractérise par deux niveaux de prise en
compte ceux qui ont travaillé avant 16
ans ils sont peu nombreux et qui peuvent
partir à 58 ans et ceux qui peuvent
partir à 20 ans qui bénéficient si l'on
peut dire de deux années de départ
anticipées nous créons un troisième
niveau pour tenir compte de ceux qui
commencent à travailler entre 16 et 18
ans c'est cette mesure ce qui va
permettre justement que l'effort que
nous attendons des Français soit le plus
justement réparti et de protéger ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler
extrêmement tôt qu'est-ce qui
aujourd'hui amène les uns et les autres
à travailler plus tard cercle relèvement
de l'âge que nous proposons mais il y a
une autre raison et vous le savez c'est
la réforme que vous et moi vont voter en
2013 vous étiez membre du gouvernement
lorsque a été voté le passage de 42 à 43
annuités la durée minimum pour avoir
droit à une retraite atoplin et
aujourd'hui je suis parfois moi aussi
perplexe j'entends votre question et je
me demande si vous défendez la position
de votre premier secrétaire traite à 60
ans avec 43 années de cotisation c'est
une machine à décote ou la position de
votre premier secrétaire délégué votre
nouveau premier skateur délégué qui
considère que cette illusoire
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur Garraud
franchement le débat sera utile monsieur
le ministre s'il est de bonne foi et si
vous ne recourez pas à la malhonnêteté
intellectuelle vous avez d'abord essayé
de nous faire croire que cette réforme
était juste personne ne vous a cru vous
avez essayé de vous faire croire que le
régime était au bord de la faillite
personne personne ne vous a cru et vous
nous dites aujourd'hui que les Français
doivent faire un effort et que vous
voulez imposer les 64 ans nous ne vous
suivrons pas davantage sortez de votre
obstination sortez de votre entêtement
et écouter les Français
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame fanta-berte pour
le groupe Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre du travail et du plein emploi
monsieur le ministre tandis que s'ouvre
cette semaine l'examen sur le projet de
loi retraite nous devons à la population
d'avancer dans un contexte serein que
l'on soit pour ou contre cette réforme
très bien que l'on soit là pour affirmer
nos convictions en particulier si elle
divergent très bien aussi c'est le but
mais il se produit ici quelque chose de
très vicieux tous les moyens sont-ils
bons pour porter nos convictions ce que
dit le texte est écarté au profit de ce
que l'on veut lui faire dire parce que
l'objectif c'est de mettre les Français
dans la rue mais du coup s'agit-il
vraiment de lutter pour l'intérêt
collectif on peut se le demander car
après l'étape qui consistait à alimenter
les plateaux TV de propos démagogues de
contre-vérité et de mensonges oui de
mensonges quand on soutient par exemple
qu'une aide-soignante atteinte de
polyarthrite partira à 64 ans alors que
le texte réaffirme que les travailleurs
handicapés prendront leur retraite à
partir de 55 ans c'est un mensonge
désormais on passe à l'étape 2 de la
communication et des agissements
tendancieux avec les fermetures des
mairies par solidarité
sous-entendant que même les instances de
la République s'opposent à cette réforme
c'est là le summum de
l'instrumentalisation la mère de Paris
évoque une mesure symbolique symbolique
oui symbolique du piège dans lequel
certains sont tombés sous couvert de
l'intérêt du peuple de vouloir gagner
par tous les moyens en popularité le
droit de grève est un droit individuel
monsieur le ministre du Travail que
pensez-vous d'un employeur qui est à
fortiori d'un employeur public qui
décrète de fermer sa structure par
solidarité avec une manifestation je
vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
[Applaudissements]
alors s'il vous plaît est-ce que le
ministre peut répondre à la question
merci merci madame la Présidente
lorsque nous sommes dans un moment de
mobilisation sociale il y a pour moi
notamment pour ce qui concerne les
agents publics et les employeurs publics
de principe qu'il s'agit de respecter
premier principe c'est le droit de grève
c'est un droit à la constitutionnel
garanti que nous respectons et chacun
peut faire grève lorsqu'il le souhaite
lorsqu'il le juge utile et un deuxième
principe qui est celui de la neutralité
du service public vous me posez madame
la députée la question du droit et
notamment
l'appréciation que nous pourrions porter
sur les déclarations les décisions de la
mère de Paris ou d'autres maires dans le
pays je pourrais évoquer la décision du
Conseil d'État de 2005 qui a rappelé que
les bâtiments publics et les mairies au
premier lieu devaient rester neutres
qu'elle ne pouvait pas être
affiché qu'il ne pouvait être affichée
de signes symbolique politique ou
philosophique sur les façades des
équipements municipaux des équipements
publics je pourrais évoquer la cour
d'appel la cour d'appel administrative
de Lyon qui a condamné la fermeture
d'une mairie qui avait fermé ses
services en solidarité avec un mouvement
social je pourrais aussi évoquer les
articles 711 et suivant du code de la
fonction publique qui rappelle qu'il y a
un principe celui du service fait qui
écarte la possibilité de payer les
agents grévistes car si la grève est un
droit le paiement de la grève et au
contraire quelque chose qui n'est pas
toléré mais au-delà de ces questions de
droits que peut-être un jour le juge
appréciera il y a une question de morale
une question politique j'ai été maire
pendant 10 ans de ma ville d'Annonay
j'ai eu mannes occasions d'être en
conflit en opposition avec les
différents gouvernements qui sont
succédés mais jamais je n'ai pris les
usagers en otages jamais je me suis
servi des services pour instrumentaliser
un procès politique et encore moins un
procès en illégitimité jamais j'étais
pesé sur les agents de la collectivité
quelques pressions que ce soit que ce
soit pour faire grève ou pour prendre le
poste je crois que c'est là le principe
de neutralité mais aussi un principe de
respect et de responsabilité
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Pierre Morin
pour le rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre je vous ai envoyé
la semaine dernière un courrier vous
devez communiquer à la représentation
nationale ce rapport que cachez-vous
vous l'avez refusé tout à l'heure et
vous osez vous féliciter d'une baisse de
5% pour les plus riches qui achètent une
voiture électrique pour les péages voilà
il est inacceptable que les Français qui
bossent trinquent sur l'hôtel de la
rentabilité des grandes entreprises
autoroutières depuis des années Marine
Le Pen demande la nationalisation des
autoroutes car il s'agit du bien commun
des Français de façon plus générale
votre gouvernement a passé les 6
dernières années à matraquer les
automobilistes avec une constance qui
frise le sadisme vous refusez de baisser
les taxes sur le carburant vous les avez
même augmenté vous instaurez des ZF pour
empêcher les plus modestes d'accéder au
centre-ville vous avez misé sur une
politique de sécurité routière du tout
répressif ma question est donc la
suivante quand allez-vous arrêter de
matraquer les automobilistes et enfin
défendre le pouvoir d'achat des Français
je vous remercie la parole est à
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Pierre Meurin il y a deux parties dans
votre question une spécifique qui
rejoint de manière totale la question de
la France insoumise et qui nous rappelle
que les propositions de Marine Le Pen
sont les mêmes que celles de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon dépenser 40 milliards pour
racheter les sociétés d'autoroute et se
retrouver dans une situation à la fin où
on utiliserait précisément l'argent des
Français pour aller le mettre dans le
rachat des autoroutes plutôt que pour
l'utiliser d'une autre manière vous
m'expliquez que nous invoquons
l'inflation le sujet n'est pas celui-là
le sujet c'est qu'il y a des contrats
qui ont été passés au milieu des années
2000 ni vous ni moi n'étions là dans ces
contrats il y a des clauses dans ces
clauses l'inflation est une clause
l'indexation du prix sur l'inflation est
présente depuis cette époque et la
réalité c'est que nous ne pouvons
augmenter les taxes ou les règles que
dans le cadre juridique applicable et
c'est exactement ce que nous faisons de
contentieux qui sont en cours notamment
de la disposition qui a été votée dans
la loi de finances de 2020 je vous
redonnerai mon adresse parce que je n'ai
pas reçu de courrier votre part me
demandant la communication de quelques
rapports que ce soit pour une raison
relativement simple c'est vous avez très
bien qu'en 2021 ou en 2020 je n'étais
pas dans cette situation maintenant plus
largement vous dépassez ça en disant le
sujet c'est le battre à cash
systématique des automobilistes monsieur
marin je sais que vous êtes un partisan
du retour inconditionnel au 90 km/h des
24 points au lieu des 12 et du fait
considérer que il faut vis-à-vis des
automobilistes passer à une espèce de
vision qui consisterait à les encourager
mais celui qui porte une vision
idéologique c'est vous la constance que
nous avons c'est la protection des
Français ça vaut pour les règles de
sécurité routière ça vaut pour la
protection contre la surmortalité qui
est liée à la pollution de nos villes et
aux moteurs diesel et ça vaut aussi et
ça vaut aussi avec la lutte contre les
règlements climatiques votre scepticisme
sur ces questions explique sans doute le
radicalisme de vos positions
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la monsieur Merin quelques secondes oui
vous m'avez pas répondu je voulais
savoir si on allait avoir la
communication de ce rapport
merci
la parole est à Monsieur Pierre
d'arriver pour le groupe GDR
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre monsieur le ministre
rue de journée pour vous
si on regarde la situation un peu
froidement avec un peu de recul vous
êtes en fâcheuse posture
alors vous avez essayé d'imposer une
réforme qui n'a pas de majorité
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
a appelé à manifester le pays est dans
la rue encore plus fort aujourd'hui il
faut mesurer je crois l'ampleur de la
colère et même dans votre majorité sur
les bancs de la droite le doute s'est
installé
vous avez déployé pourtant une énergie
considérable à essayer de convaincre à
discréditer à décourager et maintenant
monsieur le ministre il faut écrire le
scénario du retrait de l'abandon de
cette réforme qui est manifestement
illégitime c'est le plus sage
c'est ce qui vous honorerait le plus
tout le monde louer votre votre esprit
de lucidité de responsabilité car
personne ne croit quand vous parlez de
justice de progrès social personne ne
vous croit quand vous présentez en
sauveur du système tout le monde a bien
compris la brutalité de cette réforme la
dégradation sans justification du droit
à la retraite deux ans de volée tout le
monde a bien compris que votre projet
c'est d'allonger le temps de travail
d'un maximum de gens et de faire baisser
les pensions des autres finalement il
faut le prendre monsieur le ministre
avec philosophie vous avez essayé vous
n'avez pas réussi et la République va
mieux quand le gouvernement est en phase
avec la volonté populaire elle en sort
grandi quand d'un conflit on trouve
l'issue et l'apaisement dans la justice
ce sera un moment désagréable je veux
pas vous le cacher un moment désagréable
à passer mais il faut s'y préparer le
plus tôt sera le mieux monsieur le
ministre vous serez soulagé ensuite et
le monde du travail aussi sera soulagé
la seule issue raisonnable c'est de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le système serait déficitaire il
s'écroulerait et la pension le niveau
moyen de revenus au niveau de moyens des
pensions des retraités baisseraient de
20% comme c'est indiqué dans le conseil
d'orientation du corps je ne suis pas
sûr monsieur le député que vous
souhaitiez la fin du système pareil
partition et je suis encore moins
convaincu que vous souhaitiez de voir
baisser le niveau de vie relative des
retraités dans notre pays vous souhaitez
protéger les deux nous souhaitons aussi
protéger les deux c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous portons cette réforme pour
équilibrer le système pour faire en
sorte qu'il soit pérennisé et faire en
sorte que ça se passe le plus justement
possible
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
vous en aurez la semaine prochaine vous
inquiétez pas
la parole est à Madame Estelle
Youssoupha pour le groupe Eliot merci
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse aux ministres du
socle ministre du Travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion je veux prendre
ici le relais de mon collègue de Mayotte
et expliciter la réalité des retraites à
Mayotte il y a 2615 retraités à Mayotte
vous les avez oublié et vous nous
inviter à y réfléchir ensemble soit donc
actes gagnant un peu de temps et
rappelons que le plafond de calcul de la
sécurité sociale qui sert de base pour
ce calcul est fixé par le gouvernement à
65,3% du montant national c'est votre
entière responsabilité Paris Nivelles
Mayotte par le bas effectivement la
retraite moyenne est de 276 euros à
Mayotte 276 euros par mois en deçà du
seuil national de pauvreté à Mayotte
plus anciens sont condamnés à
l'indignité le système leur promet
l'indigence à Mayotte la retraite la
plus faible s'élève à 9 euros par mois
sachez que 9 euros c'est le prix du pack
d'eau à Mayotte puisque nous n'avons pas
assez d'eau potable parce qu'il est
impossible de pas parler de retraite
sans parler du coût de la vie le coût du
panier alimentaire et je vous le
rappelle 60% plus cher à Mayotte
l'inflation déplace celle de l'hexagone
et atteint 7,1% sur notre île au 1er
janvier le SMIC national est passé à
1700,09 28 euros pour l'Hexagone à
Mayotte il a été augmenté à 1290 euros
nous travaillons tout autant je rassure
tout le monde mais nous sommes payés 418
euros de moins encore une discrimination
par décret une pauvreté systémique pour
nous mahoraise et Maoré vous parlez de
justice pour cette réforme qui ne
propose rien pour Mayotte rien pour les
ultramarins rien pour les fonctionnaires
ultramarins qui voient s'éteindre
l'internité temporaire de retraite il
demande simplement
à cotiser davantage pour espérer une
retraite digne quelle justice pour les
travailleurs et les retraités de Mayotte
quelle mesure proposez-vous je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Olivier du soft ministre du Travail
merci madame la Présidente d'abord un
mot pour vous dire que nous n'avons pas
oublié les retraités de Mayotte je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure en réponse à monsieur
camardine nous savons très bien la
situation particulière du régime de
retraite à Mayotte il est très récent je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure créé en 1989
1987 pardon pour le régime de base
obligatoire il n'y a pas de régime
complémentaire obligatoire il n'y a que
2500 pensionnés aujourd'hui lorsque nous
regardons quelle est la carrière quelle
est la reconstitution de carrière des
retraités concernées il n'apparaît que 9
années réellement cotisées mais nous
savons que tout ça est finalement le
fruit d'une histoire qui a été plus
longue à construire d'un point de vue
administratif il y a des périodes de
convergence que nous observons
aujourd'hui convergence sur l'assiette
de cotisation elle doit se terminer en
2036 convergence sur le nombre de
trimestres exigés pour avoir droit à une
retraite à taux plein convergence aussi
sur les questions relatives au
complémentaires je l'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure le résultat est la situation est
pardon madame je suis allé pardon je
vais jusqu'au bout de ma réponse vous
l'avez dit vous-même la retraite moyenne
aujourd'hui à Mayotte et 287 euros
est-ce que c'est acceptable non est-ce
que c'est facile à résoudre non plus
est-ce qu'appliquer le projet tel que
nous le portons à Mayotte à la situation
des assurés et les pensionnés de Mayotte
serait possible ce n'est pas souhaitable
car les paramètres de ce projet ne
correspondent pas à la réalité connue
tant par les assurés que par les
pensionnés à Mayotte j'ai dit à Monsieur
camardine tout à l'heure mettons un
profit cette période mettant un profit
ce texte et métropole profit le travail
que nous avons à faire pour accélérer la
convergence d'accélérer la convergence
ça passe par la revalorisation des
pensions ça passe par l'accélération
tous les paramètres de la convergence je
ne sous-estime pas le travail et je sais
combien c'est une impatience que vous
traduisez aujourd'hui par la colère que
vous exprimez dans votre question
mettons-nous tout simplement au travail
le projet tel que nous le portons ne
serait pas bon s'il était appliqué à
Mayotte par contre profitons de ce débat
pour faire en sorte d'apporter des
réponses à ce que vous représenter ici
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
séance des questions au Gouvernement est
terminée la séance est suspendue